Steven shubin junior who made some bad
ass designs for the Gorilla Orangutan
Chimp and the howler monkey,
and we've added to that Zombie kettle
bells.
Why?
Because we're trendy and zombies are in
style.
Are they just painted on his intention
center?
Zombie sculptures?
Look,
I'm not on the line.
I'm looking at.
I'm showing you a screen in front of
your fat.
Stupid for you.
Yelled at me and he showed me the
screen.
I'm trying to do a commercial at the
time.
I try and do.
Here.
I'm letting you do.
I'm Joe.
We sell battle ropes and supplements and
by the way,
this is a shtick that steven brody,
Stevens and I do.
We're not really upset at each other.
Ladies and gentlemen.
No Way.
This is fun talk.
We're being fun.
Who thinks or silly people that don't
know.
Did you see the drama on the podcast
today?
Challenge Brody?
Brody.
What kind of your.
Your apartment has tons of workout gear
like like do you have any of this shit?
Do you have any of these cases or clubs
because was like,
it's hard to look around.
What's the best angle for me?
Okay.
I can see I have one of the wheel balls
on the lower right for abs ab wheel
roll.
I guess it's an Ab roller.
I have.
It looks like a medicine ball.
I have a couple of those and I have
kettle bells.
Yes,
I have a weighted vest.
and that's probably it.
Oh,
I have a jump rope.
I see that in the lower corner.
Have you ever tried battle ropes?
Those are yellow.
I do have ropes that I can sign up to my
car.
The ropes,
they're not necessarily heavy.
They're just more to be locked up on
something.
Maybe weigh a lot.
I.
I don't
know.
Oh,
so those are like the pole.
They're not like ropes,
like this big fat shipyard ropes.
You ever done these kinds of workouts?
Battle ropes?
No.
I'd like to.
I've seen them on really fun.
Awesome.
Full body workout.
You.
We have some videos available at
[inaudible] dot com.
You can learn how to do it.
It's fairly easy.
Just a bunch of different simple
exercises.
Also,
if you go online,
you see the video that we have,
but if you go online,
there's plenty of different workouts
that you could follow along.
One of the coolest things about the
Internet,
if you have questions about something,
there's a lot of generous people out
there that will give you their time for
free and show you cool shit like this,
but battle ropes is a great exercise for
functional strength and Cardio.
Really good for martial artists.
If you're into a striking or grappling,
either one of them,
you can benefit pretty substantially
from a good a kettle bell and battle
rope workout.
We also sell supplements,
all kinds of shit at onnit Dotcom,
all kinds of fantastic stuff.
We call ourselves a human optimization
website because we basically sell you
all this shit that actually works as far
as like making different areas of your
body work better.
Like shroom tech sport,
which is a great supplement for
endurance.
It's based on the quarter Sepsis,
mushroom,
a lot of vitamin B,
12 in their new mood,
which is a based on five htp
supplements,
five htp and l Tryptophan,
which converts to five htp.
All those help your brain produce more
serotonin actually get you feeling
better.
La,
la,
la.
If I went on forever about all the
groovy shit@on.com
is commercial,
be three hours long and you guys
wouldn't be listening anymore.
Let's be honest on a.com
o n and it used code named Brogan.
Save yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
Steven Brody Stevens is here.
Let's get freaky plays in general
experience.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Steven Brody Stevens is here.
He's excited.
He's a new man.
He's on comedy central now.
People are finally starting to recognize
your talent.
Brody feels good.
These motherfuckers,
they tried to hold you back for so long.
They were afraid of your originality,
your unique talents,
the vibe you give off,
all the above.
You scared the public.
You scared the private.
I think at one point maybe.
I mean,
there've been times.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask one question before on
Brian,
are there going to be the monitors
there?
I get distracted sometimes.
What do you think I should do if this
monitor?
Yeah,
maybe one of us will monitor over there.
That's bothering you.
You don't want to focus on joe gets
distracted.
Yeah,
me too.
I did a podcast.
Show them both off.
Fuck.
It will shut them both off unless we
need.
So it doesn't.
Brian have to do that now.
He doesn't have to do it.
Jamie just shut them off.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll just seeing new things like this.
I closed my left thigh and then I'm
good,
but he was.
I could see that one.
Yeah.
That bothers you.
That's like a fucking 100 yards away.
No,
but I can.
It's like right in my.
What's the Tarzan distracting me?
It's Kinda just a joke.
I did a show earlier of visual live show
and I felt like it'd be funny to where
like I said,
I've stolen Brian and these guys
earlier.
I feel like that I have a three day
window to kind of goof around A.
Again,
I'm not going to wear this out in
public,
but I'll wear it on the show a word on a
podcast that's three day window to goof
around before what a well before and
after like having that comedy central
show.
I felt like maybe before it I could be a
little more outgoing on twitter,
but to make some statements be real,
get things off my chest,
not cold man.
I put just Kinda say I wanted to share
with the audience kind of what was
going,
you know,
going on in my mind before something was
gonna happen.
I could because I knew episode one was
going to be good.
I knew that based on.
I had good reviews.
The show,
what's it called?
It's called Brody Stevens.
Enjoy it.
Great Name.
Well thank you and enjoy it if you want
to hear it.
Just.
It just came from my ear.
Early years at Arizona State.
My freshman year I would go get,
go to Mcdonald's actually like on a
Sunday and read the newspaper and the
girl working there was just a.
She was just overly positive.
Like I order a big Mac Combo and she
guys keep them off.
Oh,
it's going to show you the trailer if
you wanted to see the trailer for
Brody's.
Neisha let,
let's just talk for a while.
We'll show it later.
Um,
and she was just like so nice and like,
and she was a slightly handicapped,
but that's not the point.
Should I just remember she would slide
it across the,
uh,
the counter there and to go enjoy and it
just like,
wow.
It's like she's really into her job and
it's big dot.
It's Mcdonald's and she doesn't have to
be.
And then I saw her working at Wendy's
around the corner.
This is a true story.
I went in there and ordered a chocolate
frosty,
which at the time wasn't available.
I updated that because at one point it
was only frosties.
So anyway,
chocolate for you update it yourself.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
back in the day like chocolate frosties
and vanilla frosties,
there's only chocolate frosty.
Right?
So see when you go to Wendy's and you
said I'm going to get a chocolate
frosty.
It was redundant because they didn't
have other options.
This is in the 1988,
but anyway,
going through the drive through,
I get my drink and my food,
the double double and she reaches out
and she goes,
enjoy.
Same Lady,
different restaurant,
fast food.
Well I guess she decided that was her
living,
like maybe she dealt,
worked double shifts and it just stuck
in my mind.
Enjoy.
And then I brought it around the
baseball team at Arizona state and was
like,
enjoy,
enjoy it,
enjoy that.
Enjoy us.
It just kind of took a life of its own.
That's beautiful.
She stepped up.
She went from Mcdonald's.
Wendy's.
Wendy's is probably higher quality
burger.
Hey,
better if I have to choose between the
two.
Yeah.
Wendy's.
You feel like you're getting a little
bit.
Yeah.
It's a better.
It's a better patty.
Yeah.
It's a better patty and better,
better taste and probably a better gig
and you're sitting down there.
You feel it.
It's a little more warm.
There's it's more wood panel there.
You'll find that it's more country where
you were.
It reminds you of that one dude that
used to be an all those cars date.
He's play Santa Claus for me because my
mom used to work for the headquarters
and he would dress up as Santa Claus
every year.
And as a kid I have all these photos of
me on his lap,
him dressed up as Santa Claus and me
crying and stuff.
Oh,
the Wendy's guy made you cry.
Yeah.
Will you just cried and everything.
The winds blow and the new Wendy's girl,
I will you be quiet about Santa Claus
because you know,
was like three or four,
you know what I mean,
like three year olds who's cried
anything.
But it has me all the way up to like 14.
Like I have a picture of me old.
So,
uh,
that's where enjoy it came from.
That's where that title came from and I
just good one around the baseball team.
Enjoy it.
Yes.
And guys picked up on it and there's a
couple other phrases.
Simple was another one.
We'd play video games and I'm,
I'm better,
I'm better than you.
Simple.
So it was Kinda like that simple.
So we both enjoy it because when you
play baseball and you have to be vocal
supporting your teammates and you're in
the dugout quite a bit and you just come
up with funny stuff.
You.
I was able to rag other teams,
you know,
obviously not cursing or anything like
that,
but you know,
make fun of batterers or make fun of it.
Third basement or another picture kind
of thing.
So.
Well.
So you had these little catchphrases.
Yeah,
I got better at it.
At first I was bad.
It was like comb your hair.
It's like a roadie know you're going to
have to take it.
Take the game off.
You got to step up your,
your phrase game.
Yeah.
You learned.
Do you stick with numbers?
That's good.
Like 22 deuces.
11 sticks.
Legs,
one's arm.
She just have fun.
I had fun with like joking with numbers.
Birch.
These are the things you would yell out
while the Games going on.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Like supporting your teammates.
So like Rogan's at the play.
You're wearing number 11.
Rogan.
Yes.
Here we go.
Sticks.
Let's do it.
Making contact.
I'm great hat.
I don't know what else I was working,
but I was just something that you just
sort of picked up along the way.
I would.
Well,
I guess I kind of work on it,
but I would pick it up along the way.
Yeah,
with you.
I would say numbers.
I wouldn't say come on Rogan.
I wouldn't say it like that.
I go,
come on buddy.
I'd say that,
but then I would do the Jesus' love
yourself.
You know why?
I'll tell you why you panic.
No,
I'm not manic.
I've been dumping drinks over p a n o a
mannequin panic.
But you know what?
These are quick silver and fibia shorts.
They can.
You can wear them in the water.
Oh,
this is what's called the secret plug.
I see what you did.
Love to work with water on yourself on
purpose to get quick silver migration or
comedy central show.
You're a very smart guy in that respect
that you submitted the nets that have
been chasing.
I know you wouldn't know it.
There's somebody who knows it out there.
Somebody who knows.
What did he do?
He,
uh,
spilt water on the court to kind of
delay the game against the Lakers the
other night because it's a,
they were losing and they had to get a
time out or something.
And so once the,
uh,
spilled the court water on it,
they had to clean it up and while
they're cleaning up,
they designed to play.
It's,
I kind of cheating.
There's been a bunch of.
Yeah,
two
things over the years where guys have
done various things in the octagon that
were illegal to,
to,
to make things more slippery.
Like vaseline.
Yeah.
But when the UFC,
when you throw water on the canvas,
it actually gives you more traction.
Oh,
it does?
Yeah.
Guys actually throw water on the ground
before they fight and then they step
into that legal or no?
Yes.
Okay.
It's all good.
It's not bad.
Um,
you're not supposed to pour too much
water on yourself.
Like sometimes you'll see the referee
drying a guy off.
Oh really?
Before he goes out for the next round.
Yeah.
Because like say if you're fighting a
grappler and you come out completely
soaking wet,
like literally dripping wet,
it's way harder to grab you.
Your slippery.
You slip out of things like you're the
swim pool.
Yeah.
And that's slipperiness can make the
difference between a submission and an
escape.
Like it's that it's a big deal.
Yeah.
It's a pretty big factor.
Oil.
A lot of guys have oil,
the oil up like uh,
baby oil.
Yeah.
You know what they do?
That's cheating,
right?
Yes.
One of the things that guys have done is
they,
um,
it's been rumored that they lie and
mineral baths at night.
So they take this bath with a mineral
oils and they just soak in it for
fucking like an hour or whatever.
And then they take a shower.
Okay.
And then when they sweat the next day,
even though the skin is dry,
when they started out,
when they sweat,
they are just so lit as fuck.
But they're not technically illegal.
They're not technically illegal because
they are clean.
Like if you,
if you touch them,
you're not going to see,
you know,
not going to feel like an oily.
There's no health benefit from it.
Well,
I'm sure it's probably good for your
skin.
Really keeps you lovely.
I try to take a mineral oil bath.
There was a guy who is a actually kicked
out a coroner's.
Uh,
I dunno for life or what,
but it was for a long time because he
was rubbing vaseline on guys.
He would like do this chest massage
thing while I was doing.
It was rubbing vaseline on them.
He rubbed their neck and he was rubbing
vaseline on them.
He was actually making them more
slippery.
She has a latent.
Yeah,
it was his corner man.
It was blatant.
They were saying that they were doing
this.
Uh,
there's a guy who used to work with
fighters that claim to be like a witch
doctor.
They called them the witch doctor and he
had this whole series of things that he
would do to guys to like align their
shockers and shit.
I Dunno,
I dunno what Angelo.
Dundee?
No,
I don't remember.
I don't remember the gentleman's name,
but he used to rub dudes chests and like
a circle and pat their neck and this is
corner man was doing that right after he
applied vaseline to his face.
So whether or not it was intentional is,
you know,
only he knows that what he was doing was
with this Voodoo move with vaseline on
his hand.
Oh,
it's Kinda.
So it's kind of illegal.
Any he might not have realized he had
just put vaseline on his face.
Anderson Silva did it wants to,
if he wiped vaseline off of his face and
put it on his chest and his arms like in
front of everybody.
You don't,
they do that in boxing.
They put.
Yeah.
On your faces.
Okay.
Oh,
it is a big difference is having on your
arms and chest.
Gotcha.
Because then if guys go to clinch up
with you,
he slipped away from them and you know,
Anderson did it like really blatantly
one fight.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well they don't let them do it anymore.
They make sure you know,
there's,
you gotta realize MMA is only 20 years
old.
They're still meet.
We just celebrated the UFC,
celebrate its 20th anniversary,
so like there's a lot of rules like have
to get made up along the way and it's
still evolving.
Still some fuckery afoot pretty Stevens,
but you know what?
It's a,
it's probably the sport.
It's not going to change all that much
over the years.
I don't think it could use a few
changes.
It can be easy food changes,
but it might be say like a golf or a,
a tennis,
which is Kinda,
you know,
over the years I guess those gentlemen,
Gentlemen,
sports mma will never be that.
You don't think so you think it will
evolve into different rules or
different.
It's always going to be really primal
because that's what would its appeal is,
its appeal is and in this water down
society where everything's nerfed and
the whole world is fucking sanitary.
There's one sport where shit gets
real as real,
as fun.
It does two dudes who are pushing
themselves for five minutes per round in
a championship match.
You're talking about 25 minutes of
ferocity in Connecticut Energy and just
thinking and sweat and blood and
injuries and through things and trying
to overcome.
I mean,
it's a fucking,
it's primal.
Primal gets the most exciting sport of
all time and you're right up there with
baseball.
Ah,
how dare you know,
daily.
Even compare those.
That's what I always,
when people complain about ground,
fighting over a guy holding a guy down
in the ground and I'm like,
as boring as it is,
it's not as boring as baseball.
Baseball,
fuck.
I don't watch a lot of baseball.
You watch plenty.
No.
I like going watch too much.
No,
I don't have much.
Not very much.
How much is not very much.
Um,
I mean,
I,
I don't honestly,
I don't,
I don't watch a lot of TV.
Don't lie to America.
Brody Stevens.
I'll tell you what I like about
baseball.
I like going down early before the fans
get there,
hanging out with the team,
watching the batting practice,
playing grab ass if you want to,
if you want to call it that 10 percent
having fun.
Um,
that's what I then stay for a few
innings and then go home.
Well,
it seems like your sense of humor
actually was kind of developed from the
comradery of like hanging out with guys
that you were playing with,
so that makes sense that you would enjoy
that camaraderie.
Like enjoy it.
I enjoy it.
It in a simple like making and making
everybody laugh that you got that
camaraderie of like teammates,
like working out together,
hanging out together.
Like people who've never experienced
that sort of environment.
They don't really totally understand it,
do they?
I would,
I would think not only because,
yeah,
I got to play baseball and first of all
at Arizona state and we're flying
around.
We had to be professionals and represent
the university.
And then yeah,
going off the plane,
the summertime up to Alaska and you're,
you're up there and you're meeting guys
from different schools and you're,
yeah,
you're traveling,
you're sharing hotel rooms and lot of
those experiences.
Yeah.
And then they'll the locker room stuff
and the parties and the jokes on the bus
and getting in trouble as a team at,
you know,
I,
I'm dad helped us define who I am.
It defined.
I,
I enjoyed that.
Yes.
You know,
having that,
I think that that's something that
everybody could use.
I think that's one of the benefits of
competing in a sport is that you go when
you hang out with a bunch of people that
are also doing the same thing and you
learn together,
you know,
I think that's missing from a lot of
people.
Man.
I think that's missing from a lot of
people.
Never get involved in sports.
Yeah.
I would add would after the.
I mean my freshman year I would always,
because I wasn't a top guy so I didn't
get the instruction from the coaches
like the top recruit.
So I would go to the other,
the other pitchers of senior pictures
and I say,
can you guys
help me out a little bit with my
mechanics?
And there was a,
a big a window where you can look in and
work on your throwing mechanics.
And these guys would work with me,
so I didn't like,
I knew the coach was focusing on these
other guys and I never got upset about,
oh,
I'm not in the game.
I'm not good enough.
I just said I want to become,
you know,
the best picture I could be and work on
my mechanics difference in pitching
between the really awesome dudes.
The guys would get scouted and a guy
like you.
What's the difference?
Well,
I,
I did get scouted,
but I would say,
you know,
what they look for today is probably,
size is a Gigaton of fill into his body.
Um,
you know,
having long arms,
a good attitude,
you know,
is there a motion going to be where
they're not gonna hurt their shoulder
hurt their arms.
So they're motion as far as the way they
throw.
Yeah.
You can see a guy how he throws,
like naturally he may throw we strange
where I can see an injury coming on if
he doesn't adjust that.
Whereas some guys had jeff perfect
smooth mechanics and it's,
they're very specific technique when it
comes to throwing a hardball.
I think there's,
there's specific techniques,
gas and then there's,
I mean within that there's some coaches
and some philosophies that have
variations on that,
so,
but there's a few famous guys who
deviate,
right,
like they go,
they throw side arm.
Yeah.
Their side armors are,
I mean a sidearm or could be.
Yeah,
they just get more action.
They throw over the top and there were
an okay picture,
but they figured out that those side arm
and that book's act different action on
the ball and some guys can't do that or
don't want to do that or you don't have
to show baseball.
James,
that's brody pitching at Arizona State
pitchers.
Brody,
you're on youtube.
I guess I have one video of me pitching
on Youtube.
How did you do?
I gave up a home run.
It's just the alumni game.
It's the only time you've ever pitched?
No,
I patched my.
I pitched,
I think my record was foreign one.
I pitched three years.
I was injured here and there,
but I pitched.
I was four and one.
I think I had a few saves.
My era was three point something.
I 28 strike out and maybe had 31.
I had more strikeouts per innings and I
had a 11 walk.
What's that one crazy surgery that
baseball players,
Tommy Johns elective,
the Tommy John Surgery.
How does that work?
You take a ligament out of your wrist
and you put it in your elbow.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
that's Kinda what it was.
That was the,
uh,
back in the day it was,
they would say you hurt your right arm.
They would probably take the poll maris
tendon at the time.
So they would usually take it out of
your,
your left wrist and they put it in your,
your right elbow.
And they would do a figure eight,
kind of tightened it up.
Boom.
That's the,
uh,
the Tommy John.
Now they'll take maybe a,
a ligament from your leg
or maybe a dead body or even your,
the same arm and they put it in there.
So over the years it's gotten,
I think the surgery is,
is become more common place
elective surgery on some guys.
Some guys they don't even have an
injury.
They do it because it gives them more
power.
Um,
I would say no.
I would say.
What do you mean?
No?
I know guys have done it.
That baseball players that have said my
arm's fine guys have done.
I mean,
I don't know if it's been high level
pros,
but I know it was reading an article
about,
okay.
It's called a Tommy John Surgery who
shares the same birthday as me.
Oh my goodness.
Tommy John Surgery too.
He still paid similar Tommy John
Surgery.
The next steroids.
Look at this when it comes to high
school and college sports,
young athletes often urine for bigger
muscles to enhance their performance,
but for student baseball,
pitcher strength isn't so much of a
goal.
That is speed throwing speed and now
student athlete's looking for a way to
get extra boost in their pitching arm
had been putting their hopes in an
elective surgery surgery called the
Ulnar collateral ligament
reconstruction.
More famously known as Tommy John.
Okay.
I had something very similar to that.
There's okay.
It says that,
yes,
they're doing it on purpose.
I've read many articles about this.
This isn't like a secret or these high
schoolers.
These are.
Yes,
high school and college athletes.
Okay.
I.
Thank you for bringing that up and I
knew,
I know this is the Joe Rogan experience
and you're going to learn stuff and I
did.
I learned that if you're asking me right
now,
2013,
is there a major leaguer that has
electively like one of these kids in
high school and we know we have a
problem with high schools and parents
and the pressure of all that.
Is there a major leaguer currently or
within the past year or two who is
electively gone,
non-injury,
electively taken that surgery and
continued to be in the major leagues and
maybe improved.
My guess is no,
that's my.
That's my instinct.
That's my guess is that has it has not
happened,
but you know,
we'll see what happens with this high
school kid or anything.
You know though,
if all these kids are getting it done,
you don't think that some,
some people have gotten that done?
I,
I.
Because why would you say that?
Well,
here's the deal.
If you tear your ligament,
you need the surgery.
That's a fact.
If you have the ligament and it's
chronic,
it's not necessarily torn.
It's worn down,
it's off the bone.
You're probably going to need the
surgery and the reason why these guys
come back stronger,
it's not because the ligament is
stronger.
I mean that may have something to do
with it,
but a lot of people also think it's the
training because you hurt your elbow.
You're going to have to really go extra
and out of the way to make sure that
elbow is strong,
so when you're doing the rehab,
you're reaching into the ice,
you're doing all the ultrasound on your
elbow,
the exercises,
you're doing extra actually,
and that's another reason why people
come back stronger and I do think that
yeah,
it doesn't make you bionic,
but a lot of guys have come back for
that surgery and a thrown harder and if
continued their career,
I think it's yet to be known.
If a guy who elects to do it in high
school or college,
it's going to make them throw harder.
You know,
if they're hurting and they got it,
I understand if they're having chronic
pains in their elbow and their mechanics
are such where it's not going to get
better,
it's only going to get worse.
So you better adjust your mechanics and
on top of that,
yeah,
let's get the Tommy John Surgery and see
what happens.
Injury has been proven to have a
significant effect on the mechanics of
your arm.
I think it makes your arms stronger.
It makes it,
makes it throw faster.
I think.
I don't agree.
Well,
I don't know if you know that because I
don't think you've got it done and all
these people are saying it is.
All these doctors,
they're not based.
They're not pictures.
Yeah.
But they're working with pitchers.
They're talking about.
They're talking about getting this done
takes a year to recover.
Yeah.
Almost two years actually to it.
Most guys come back,
fully strength back to normal,
a year and a half to two years,
put some more strength in your elbow.
And the risks are that,
um,
sometimes after their elbow gets
reconstructed or just the add this
additional ligament,
uh,
it becomes permanently stiff and their
muscles tear or they can have something
called I magenic physician induced
problems with their elbows because of
the surgery.
Say That's not good.
No,
it's not good.
But it's,
it's fascinating that people are doing
this,
that guys are going to.
It's not a small trend either.
There's quite a few guys that are going
to the doctor and they,
they think the doctors saying that they
see the doctors explaining the
rehabilitation process and how long it
takes.
No,
it'll take like up to a year to recover
is what they're saying.
But they're saying that it does have a
significant impact
on May.
It's my phone.
The throwing harder.
Yeah.
I don't agree.
Okay.
That's my opinion at mile at might allow
you to whip your arm more like more arm
whip [inaudible].
But arm whip is not.
I mean that's going to add a mile or
two.
But I'm not a believer in it.
I,
I don't.
I want to see a major leaguer that has
had that done and you know,
and,
and electively with no injury,
maybe a cron.
I had the surgery done.
I didn't have a tear.
I had chronic injuries in my elbow.
My elbow wasn't getting better.
I had bad mechanics.
I got an MRI and they go,
you know what,
the ligament,
I see damage in there.
I can't tell there is damage in your
elbow.
And then they,
oh,
and he asked me,
uh,
you may need Tommy John Surgery,
do you want to take the tendon out of
your left elbow,
left wrist?
And I go,
yes.
And they did the surgery and he saw that
my ligament was intact and he stapled it
back down to the bone and he tightened
me up and that wasn't the Tommy John
Surgery.
But
yeah,
a lot.
A lot of people who agree with you
apparently also about the rehabilitation
that that's really what's helping them
and that it's not necessarily the,
uh,
throwing harder throwing.
It's not necessarily the ligament,
but that it might just be the
rehabilitation,
the emphasis that you put into
rehabilitation that yeah,
that was.
Maybe you can do,
but maybe you.
Maybe you can do that on your.
Once you do that in any way.
Yeah,
I think it's actually pretty
controversial,
but I'm gonna I'm gonna.
Ask around.
Yeah,
I will.
I wouldn't do it.
I W I would wait until you have a
chronic injury or it pops in tears like,
you know,
you did it,
mine was a chronic buildup thing and it
was due to bad mechanics,
so if you have bad mechanics and you get
this elective surgery ahead of time,
you're still going to have bad mechanics
and you know what?
Some people have to get a second
surgery.
It's not just the one time.
You can tear it again.
Actually.
Yeah.
That's super common with the knees guys
who have acl reconstructions,
they blow it out all the time.
I can think of several fighters,
dominick Cruz,
current bantamweight champion had his
acl reconstructed,
blew it out.
How to have it done again.
So He's been out almost two years when
he fights Hanan Barao the unify,
the title barrel had a,
they had a crown in the interim
champion.
So hennen and Michael Mcdonald went
after it.
Great fight.
And Hanan Barao became the interim
champion.
And now because he's the interim
champion or is it?
No,
what did he win the title from?
Wow.
Am I wrong about that?
I might be wrong about that.
But Michael Mcdonald challenge for the
title.
I think brow beat somebody else for the
But Anyway,
um,
the uh,
the instances of guys getting their
knees reconstructed and blowing them out
again is real high.
It's the same knee,
same knee or the other knee.
I've had both my knees reconstructed.
Derek rose,
I don't know if you follow basketball.
He blew out his left knee.
He is on the bowls that he's a million
dollar $100,000,000
player and he blew out his knee.
His,
I guess his left one of his knees and he
took a year off and people gave them a
hard time because people do come back
actually after nine or 10 months with an
acl.
And he didn't come back and then he came
back this year and he was playing and he
did the same thing to his other knee.
He,
um,
I was helen burroughs incorrect.
He defended against Michael Mcdonald.
He won the title with the decision over
Uriah Faber.
I should've known that.
That was way back in January or July of
2012.
So Dominick Cruz had been rehabbing all
this time,
sitting on the sidelines even before
then because they had to come up with an
interim title back then.
The poor guy has been out for two whole
years.
It's crazy due to these knee issue knee
issues,
man.
And with him it's very important because
his style,
he's probably got the most elaborate
footwork style in all of mma.
The dude is tireless and he goes five
rounds of constant moving.
It's one of the problems with fighting
him.
He's never there.
He's like a willow.
The wisp,
you know,
his,
his footwork is spectacular.
So a guy who was coming back from
essentially two significant operations
to his knee and two years on the shelf
and he's got that crazy style.
But you know,
knees,
you're hearing guys like coby Brian,
go into Germany and getting some of
that.
Whatever they do in Germany I had done
here in America,
it's called Regina keen ahead,
head and neck.
It's fantastic.
It does work.
It's amazing what a,
what's it's called Magento keen or Ortho
keen and in Germany,
um,
Magento kind,
keen,
whatever the fuck it is,
they take your blood out.
It took a lot of it,
like almost a leader.
And then they expose it to environmental
factors and spinning it in a centrifuge.
Doing that.
It produces this reaction to the heat
that they expose it to.
Produces this yellow liquid,
which is the most potent anti
inflammatory drug known to man produced
by your own body,
your own body.
Cool.
So it's amazing stuff and they now do it
in Santa Monica that they do it in
Dallas.
Excuse me.
They do it at a couple different,
I think they do in Vegas now as well.
But fighters are experienced miraculous
results with us and know Chris Weidman
hadn't done on his knees.
A lot of different fighters are getting
it done and different parts of their
body,
their backs especially,
so they're waiting to their injured to
do it.
Oh yeah.
It does no benefit.
If you were an injured,
it's just anti inflammatory,
so don't take it unless you are hurt,
but the people who are hurt like elbow
injuries,
sore elbow,
sore knees,
experience profound changes because of
this.
It's really amazing and it's healthy.
Oh,
it's totally healthy.
It's your blood.
It's your own body.
There's nothing dangerous about it
whatsoever,
but what's really fascinating is that
these guys are figuring out all these
different ways to get your body to heal
itself.
I mean,
that's essentially what they're doing.
They're reintroducing your body's own
anti inflammatory response to get it to
fix itself.
That's amazing,
man.
That's,
that's like,
that's really like,
that's incredible shit and they're.
They're doing this now.
What are they going to have in two
years?
What are they going to have in five
You know,
but will they have because they're going
to have.
I think within our lifetimes we're going
to see genetic genetic manipulation to
the point where they can alter your
frame.
I mean,
you're hearing that kind of stuff.
hgh for example,
that is available to the public.
No,
it's not.
you can get.
There's certain companies that are
starting to make.
It's called secretagogue.
It's,
it's,
uh,
an hgh that is um,
without.
I don't even know if you'd have to get a
doctor's prescription because what it
does is it stimulates your body's own
production of hgh using a certain
combination of amino acids and minerals
and you can,
you can definitely stimulate the growth
of it with amino acids.
That's pretty much been proven that you
could raise your levels significantly
where you could see it will show up
several percent and that you would get
benefit out of that.
But as far as like real human growth
hormone,
now Sarah is so tropin and that kind of
stuff,
you have to get it from a doctor.
Okay.
So it is available that's prescribed and
most sports it's illegal.
Okay.
So it's prescribed and I know they have
these one anti aging clinics in Florida
and the guy's gotten exactly.
That's where these guys go.
Is that good for you?
And is that,
is that something that people take and
what's not a blank statement?
Is Salt good for you?
Yes.
Salts.
But if you need a pound,
you're dead.
Right?
So you know by asking his hgh or human
growth hormone and testosterone and at
these doses,
yes,
if you're doing it correctly,
yes it is good for you.
But it also improves performance without
a doubt.
And the question is should you be
allowed to do that and compete in
sports?
I don't know.
You know,
there's like a big argument with that
right now in fighting because of
testosterone use exemptions and it's a
very controversial subject with a lot of
different opinions on both sides.
And there's fighters that are taking
testosterone and it helps them recover
and it's so it's,
you know,
it definitely is good for you.
If you take it,
it'll definitely help you recover.
But what's the difference between you
taking it,
you recovering quicker and a guy who
might have the same levels as you and
doesn't take anything.
And when you're,
when you're training all the time,
your body gets beaten down and your body
has naturally low levels because you're
pushing it to the limit.
You're trying to get your body to
respond.
You have to make sure you sleep 10
hours,
12 hours a night.
You got to make sure you drink shit,
loads of water.
You got to make sure your nutrition is
on point super clean.
And if you do all those things,
you can maximize your hormone levels
naturally.
If you're a young,
healthy man.
But if you don't do that,
if you don't get the right sleep,
if you're stressed out,
if you don't eat right,
if you overtrain,
you could easily show low levels.
You go to a doctor and the doctor says,
well,
you've got low testosterone sunrail and
give you a testosterone use exemption
and you'll be better than ever.
You will be better than ever.
That's true.
But the question becomes when is it,
when should it be illegal?
And then where do we stop?
Because there's a lot of testosterone's,
a testosterone supplements that you can
take that are natural over the counter
stuff.
There's a lot of different ingredients
and testosterone boosters that has been
shown to have fairly significant
increases in your body's ability to
produce testosterone.
I'd start with that.
Yeah,
but the problem is where does it end?
Is my point.
If you make testosterone illegal,
if you say,
okay,
a guy can't take tests,
can you take creatine?
Kenny,
take amino acids.
Can you take vitamins?
Can he take a bunch of things outside?
They're not going to go back,
are they?
I don't know.
You tell me.
I don't think so.
But why not?
When things are improving,
if things are helping,
they're helping.
And if it's testosterone,
what about vitamin B?
12.
That's legal,
right?
Yes.
But can you take it in an intramuscular
shot?
Because that really increases
performance.
Can you know?
Yes,
you can.
Okay.
But why should you be able to?
Why should you be able to take vitamin B
12 and you can't take testosterone.
Why should you be able to take
testosterone if you can't take some
synthetic thing that someone creates?
It turns you into a fucking super freak
it.
The real question becomes,
where do we draw the line as far as how
much you much.
This is what I think.
I think there's going to be a point in
time where it's like the Internet,
like if one point in time when they
first created the Internet,
you might have been able to keep a porn
site off,
but at this point it's a joke.
It's just out there.
There's no way you're going to stop
people from seeing naked people if they
go.
If they go online and they're curious,
they're going to find what they're
looking for us.
I think we're going to have in just
everyday life,
so many options to enhance your body.
I think it's going to be staggering and
I think the idea of a natural athlete
100 years from now is going to be a
joke.
I don't think there's going to be any
and I don't do it in bodybuilding right
now.
What does that mean?
They have guys who do steroids and they
have guys who do natural.
No,
they have guys who claim to be natural,
but there's a lot of those guys used to
do steroids.
Okay.
And then they stopped doing steroids and
now they do natural and they've gotten
significant benefits because of that.
Like a friend of mine got into,
he was a natural bodybuilder and quotes.
He was actually natural and you got in a
big argument with one of those guys,
you know,
the guy was fucking huge.
He said the guy was ripped and strike at
it and the guy did Roy.
It's for like a long time,
but now he's clean and he's like,
so like you,
you did.
You got all this from steroids.
Like you don't look like a regular
person.
You're,
you're huge.
That came from steroids.
You just figured out how to keep it
naturally.
But the benefits all came from doing
steroids.
I could see that.
I mean,
I,
I guess most of those guys may have been
former steroid users.
A lot of them I,
I'd have to study up on.
Well,
I think when you're dealing with a sport
that essentially requires that at the
professional level in bodybuilding
require steroids at the professional
level,
probably they,
you know,
they probably do in football,
unfortunately.
I'm maybe basketball.
I think you could get by and football if
you're some sort of Ray Lewis,
super athlete type dude,
I think you can get by naturally.
I don't know,
it's just,
it's hard.
Your speculation on my part.
I have zero experience in football,
but I do know some giant dudes who were
just naturally giant,
but you can't get giant like bodybuilder
giant.
Get that big.
That's not a natural look.
That's through synthetics only one way.
There's only one way.
You can't do it any other way.
I don't.
I literally don't even think it's
possible.
I don't want to be that way.
I just want to want to look a little fit
will little fit,
you know?
I think that's good.
You know,
I stay away from a lot of the
supplements because I feel like some of
them get me going too much.
In what way?
I'm not saying any of these.
Uh,
I think if I was to take a testosterone,
I don't think it would be good for me.
You think you would have a problem
keeping it together?
Maybe I'd have to start off slow.
Maybe it'd be good for you and maybe
part of what's making you a loose cannon
and you don't have enough hormones in
your system.
I'm a loose cannon without it.
Without it.
You're just a loose cannon.
I actually,
I'm not a loose cannon.
I.
Holy Cow.
I'm not.
Some people think I am,
but uh,
no.
I'm not a loose cannon.
I take twitter.
Outrage or outburst is not a loose
cannon.
Make that happen of manic behavior on
twitter.
Are you talking about recently or
before?
For.
Yeah,
it happened,
but something happened recently.
Only recently.
I,
I know I.
No,
no,
it was just I was,
I,
like I said,
I gave myself that 72 hours because the
premier of the show was coming out and I
knew just.
I'm not even talking about whatever
comes next regarding that.
When you say you gave yourself 72 hours,
we're going way back to the earlier
conversation.
When you're talking about your hat and
your wacky attire.
Yes.
Okay.
So what you're saying is connected to
it.
Okay.
What you're saying?
Totally confused.
So let me,
and I'm sure other people are as well,
so I don't think they are for sure they
are.
If I am,
I'm not unique in that respect.
So what you're saying is you get wacky
like 72 hours between like a day and
half before,
day and a half after to sort of promote
it.
There's some of that.
Yes,
there are some of that.
Yes.
So I would say for when I say 72 hours,
I'm talking about this past Saturday,
Sunday and then Monday part of Monday.
Right.
I get to not gloat but kinda like feel
good about it.
Say thank you to everybody.
Gavi,
emotion.
Some tears.
Like this is a,
it was a big moment for me.
Like I said,
it doesn't matter what happens after
this.
I don't have to be in another movie.
I don't think.
I'm not even a.
my inspiration is not to do the brody
move.
He like Woody Allen or the Brody Sitcom.
I feel like,
you know what,
that,
that first and second episode I got
enough positivity and stress relieving a
emotions out of it to where I'm good and
I kinda,
I kinda had an outside feeling going in
that might happen.
So in my head I gave myself 72 hours.
So a lot of it before was,
you know,
thank you.
Thank you to everybody and after this
I'm going to not have to explain myself.
I don't have to be.
I'm brody,
I do this.
Why are you not laughing?
I get to like stay in the stage onstage.
Like you'll get your crowd to come see
you.
They'll understand your sense of humor.
So what you're saying,
I think a little bit of that and I also
think maybe creatively in a professional
situation,
I'm not going to have to.
I mean I'm a.
I'm not a me,
me,
me guy.
Wha Wha wha wha.
Whoa.
What'd you just say?
What the fuck did you just say?
You said you're not a me,
me,
me.
I'm not.
Okay Joe,
I've done 2,500
audience warmups.
How could I be a meme?
Miga?
Well,
just in every time we have a
conversation that comes back to me,
me,
well,
maybe I was in that situation.
I know that we could go off to the
deepest,
darkest recesses of space and you would
go,
I guarantee you I'm not really into
space ever since I was a kid,
baseball was my thing and you'll just
turn it.
Would you say since the beginning of
this podcast today,
I've been in a good frame of mind.
Positive or listening?
Yeah,
because I know I kind of.
I don't have to.
Not necessarily to you.
I never had to explain myself to you.
Bringing it back to you again,
will you never know what you're doing is
you're on this.
Oh,
I never.
I never felt I had explained myself to
you.
I felt at times I had to explain myself
to others.
Those people,
those people don't understand comics.
That's relieves stress for me and I
think that relieving of stress,
it's kind of carried over to maybe our
relationship here today and other things
I've done and our relationship here
today is different than our relationship
for the past decade or so that we've
known each other.
I feel more relaxed and that's not.
That's not you.
That's what you're saying.
So you feel like because of your
success,
you've.
It's alleviated some pressure,
you feel more better about the future
and it's allowed you and enhanced you in
all of your dealings.
Essentially for the 72 hour period.
It's allowed me to gloat a little bit.
You don't need the glow,
but now I know you're going to say that.
Joe,
how'd you know?
Because you know me.
I know you.
My path is a little different than
yours.
Your past path is unique.
Brian's path is unique.
Everybody's path.
Is it unique?
Okay.
If you could file Brian home the GPS and
be like,
what the fuck are you doing?
It's five in the morning,
go home.
So for that I gave myself 72 hours to
party.
If you talk about 72 hours,
one more time,
we're going to lose everyone listening
to this.
Why didn't you say that?
Because it's true.
Three days.
People are people are there enough right
now.
They're filled up with 72 hours.
Then they're like,
well,
this guy shut the fuck up.
About a 72 hours.
I don't think so.
We just brought up the fact that he
brings it back to himself.
What does he do?
He's back to his 72 hours to watch.
I'm going to say so uncontrolled today.
Thank God you don't have a job.
You ever think about that buddy,
that you've made it this far without
accent mean you've had some warmup gigs,
but not a job job.
We have to show up at a fucking office.
I've been lucky.
Asshole.
Did you see this lawsuit that's going on
right now?
Where this,
uh,
this CEO of this,
it's actually pretty funny.
The CEO of Archie comics allegedly would
call all the men that worked the office
penises.
She called everyone penises and she
would like.
She would have these rants where she
would scream,
penis,
penis in the staff meetings,
so these guys are suing her.
She's being sued for gender
discrimination and she says that the
suit is baseless.
She can't be guilty of gender
discrimination against employees because
white males aren't a protective class.
They aren't a protected class.
That's hilarious.
She's saying that white males don't
deserve protection,
so she might be a feminist,
but saying that she could just yell out
sexual discrimination from a position of
power being the CEO of a company,
terrify her male workers,
but because they're white men,
they can't say shit.
That is he see thinking,
run a muck.
That is the very problem with stopping
jokes and censorship and all this rape
culture bullshit.
That's the very problem unequal thinking
across the board.
Whereas non guilty people are guilty.
Do you think she may be doing on purpose
as a joke because it is archie comics
and said,
you know how many people are probably
picking up an archie comic now?
Brian is probably the best thing you
could ever do.
If you want to sell archie comics,
who buys those fucking things?
I mean,
I would.
I would say that would be brilliant if
that's the case,
but if it's not the case,
she's just another asshole boss.
You know,
being a boss of a group of men was
probably really frustrating.
Anyway.
If you're a woman,
you know,
especially if any of them are like
average men for Dick heads that don't
want to listen to a woman,
it's probably a disaster.
So how does she respond to that?
She's fucking screams at him called
cosmo penis.
It's actually kind of brilliant.
But this is.
This is such ass backwards thinking that
like the demonizing of innocent white
males has gotten to a point,
and I don't want to Belabor this because
I know white males have it easier than
anybody in this society.
There's no doubt about that,
but just the fact that anybody thinks
that they can say that,
that she can't be guilty of gender,
gender discrimination against employees
because white males aren't a protected
class.
So what she's inferring is that white
males have like,
they have a surplus,
you have a like a bunch of like get out
of trouble,
free cars throughout your whole life.
So because of that you,
oh,
so she can shit on you,
ruin your life,
ruined your day,
call you a penis at work,
do whatever the fuck she wants to do,
and you have no recourse.
That's absolutely brilliant.
It's hilarious.
There's,
there's assholes in the world,
no doubt about it.
There's,
there's racists,
there's homophobes,
there's massage,
there's missing dri,
there's people that hate men.
There's people that hate women.
There's no doubt about it.
But when you have someone who's yelling
out like penis,
penis,
either it's funny or they're an asshole
and you don't know unless you're there.
And I would imagine that these guys went
out of their way.
They work at a fucking comics place,
allegedly.
They have senses of humor.
If they went that far out of their way
to file a fucking lawsuit,
that must be a disastrous to work.
Our sheets,
comics,
the accusations are extremely damaging
to myself and archie comics.
Archie comics,
to me,
stands for high values that are global
values.
Okay.
I hate her already.
I hate anybody who would say that.
Archie comics stands for high values,
their global values.
What the fuck does that mean?
There was a nice message because of our
global values.
She is rarely even in the office.
I go around the world to promote archie
comic.
She told the Daily News.
That's what I do.
According to the employee suit,
she also invites Hell's angels into the
office to intimidate employees.
Again,
this isn't real.
This is not off the onion.
No,
it's all raw story,
which is a real legit website.
Frequently in Qa inquires about the
location of a handgun and 750 rounds of
ammunition.
She believes her late husband kept in
the office.
This sounds like horseshit.
Well,
she's got a 47 followers on twitter.
Hala.
It's probably all from today,
from this raw story in 2011.
The other CEO,
Jonathan Gold,
while they're file a suit against her
claiming that she is unstable and
bankrupting the company.
The case was settled with the parties
agreeing to hire a go.
Between Samuel Levitan to facilitate
communication between this chick and her
employees.
However,
earlier this year the go-between filed a
lawsuit against her claiming that she
had become unhinged and that she needed
to be removed.
I love this lady.
Oh,
you like these are reality show.
Be Great.
Give it.
Just give her an office full of fucking
slumpy like doofus.
He dudes that she could fucking scream
at.
So you blame the guys for being weak and
not standing up to her.
No,
they have a job.
She's an asshole obviously.
Just.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know what she's really like.
Maybe if I worked there and yelled at
people,
I'm,
I was there.
You bring it back to yourself again.
Maybe if I was there,
I didn't even do that.
We have.
If I was there,
I would think,
you know,
hey,
you know these,
these people don't have a sense of
humor,
man.
She's awesome.
Maybe I would think that it's everybody
else.
I would have to be there to make that
judgment call,
but looking at this,
it sounds pretty crazy.
Bitch.
Sounds nuts.
She's pretty hell's angels into the
office to intimidate the employees and
frequently inquires about the location
of a handgun at 750 rounds of
ammunition.
Like what the fuck that Shit happen?
Wouldn't you just go with it?
And just like,
like if she called you a penis,
et Cetera,
you'd be like,
oh,
what kind,
you know,
like it seems like she's just an
inviting to be able to throw things back
at her if she had a sense of humor.
But she's the boss man.
Yeah.
But she's saying she has that fucking
guy and I'd be like,
Oh,
I can't joke about that.
It's not nice to joke about that.
But I think the position of a boss like
that have a big office where everybody
has like real strict behavior rules.
Like when you're in a big office like
you,
everybody's wearing like nice clothes.
They have to dress like they're in an
office.
They'll go in their cubicle or their
offices and they get their work done.
It's like a very like buttoned down,
controlled,
restricted environment in most offices.
Someone running around yelling penis,
penis,
penis.
But if it's the boss and she's calling
everybody penises,
that makes you feel like,
shit,
what country is this?
This is America.
This is in New York.
It's New York.
I,
uh,
maybe she's saying peanuts.
No,
I can't.
I ain't trying to put a positive spin on
it.
Joe.
I didn't make it about me.
I don't think there's any positive spin
to be had in this one.
I think.
Um,
have you.
Have you seen pretty hilarious story.
Have you watched a birdies noosa yet?
Don't bring me.
No,
I have no,
don't bring me up actually.
Really good.
Can we show you're in it,
by the way?
Beautiful.
How about,
how did I get in it?
I had a red band sign your waiver.
Sweet.
Hope it worked out.
He came into the ice house once.
You were good at it.
Thank you.
I mean that.
Oh No,
thank you.
You know,
I wanted to come on here and say how Joe
was one of the first comedians.
I came up to me and said,
I was funny.
Like I believed that he was a guy who
was working in various.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I didn't believe that or feel it.
How come you didn't believe that?
I just didn't.
Why not?
I don't know.
I got my issues.
But people were laughing.
You hear people laughing.
Yeah.
But for you to you.
For you,
you're one of the early comedians are
2000 and say I'm funny.
You said I was funny and I believed it.
And then you,
you know,
you brought me in to do the warmup of
demand show and you were hilarious in
that,
you know,
so that gave me a lot of confidence.
That's awesome.
That's good to hear man.
You know,
everybody gets that when you're coming
up you get that boost from somebody that
you,
like.
Someone comes up to you and tells you
that you're funny.
It's a great boost.
It can make.
I always credit mark Marin when I was an
open mic or Marin came up to me once and
he gave me a compliment and gave me some
advice and I was like,
wow.
For me it was like Holy Shit.
Like this is a guy like a professional
and he's telling me I can do this.
You know,
it's very,
it's very inspirational when someone
comes up to you and gives you some
prompts,
you know,
unless you know you're doing the right
thing.
Yeah.
It feels like you maybe like,
don't know what the fuck.
You know.
Everybody feels like beginning,
right?
Yeah.
It's nice when those little moments
happen and keep working,
keep pushing.
You don't look for them.
Just keep going.
You're doing your.
Yes.
One of the most exciting things about
life is when you trying to do something
and you don't know if it's going to
happen,
you don't know if it's gonna work out
one of the most exciting things in life.
It's like trying to figure out how to
make this so because even if you have
confidence,
but how much confidence do you really
have?
It hasn't happened yet.
You know,
you might have real confidence,
but it doesn't feel like a reality until
all of a sudden here,
brody,
here's your check for doing standup
comedy and you're like,
I'm a professional now.
Like legitimately,
and then here,
brody,
you're on comedy central.
Now I like comedy central,
like legitimately like it's you then.
Then you could feel it and see it,
but man,
those early days,
like the 2013 years ago today,
if you stop and think about it,
you were a guy who is,
you know,
trying to put it together with an
uncertain future and no one knew,
you know,
what you didn't know,
you were,
you were hoping that it would all work
out,
but it was this thing where you're
trying to figure it out and make it
work.
That's so exciting.
Then it's one of the coolest things
about life.
If you can find more of those things
that you could fit in your life where
you're not really sure if it's gonna
work out the more of those you could fit
in the better.
Yeah.
It is like you just gotta you just gotTa
go for it and follow your instinct.
Simple.
You got it.
And No,
I did come out here and knowing what
would happen,
I had no idea.
And uh,
you know,
I had a couple TV,
small little team.
That was something when I,
when I did the Craig kilborn show,
that was a.
What do you play on Brian?
A little bit at the show in the.
Well actually why don't you actually
play it then do it when he's not talking
though.
Alright.
You want me to not talk?
No,
no.
Tell me when did you start in Arizona?
No,
I actually,
I mean I took an acting class at Arizona
state because I wasn't around baseball
so much,
which it is kind of a jock world and you
know,
that's cool.
But then when I had some extra credits,
I took an acting class.
Yeah.
People said,
hey brother,
you're funny.
I never was,
you know,
I never went to the Tempe Improv.
I never did an open mic.
Nothing.
I would just played baseball and went to
school and I remember I'd be up in the
study hall and a couple of football
players and say,
hey brody,
you're funny.
You should do stand up.
I would make the other like the
volleyball team laugh or the track and
field we all studied together.
So uh,
the last year,
so I took an acting class so they had
credits and it was fun,
it was supportive.
I went in there and it wasn't jocks,
it was supportive artists and girls and
it felt good and I try to do something
serious but I got laughs and I tried to
be serious and it was busting up
laughing but I liked the feeling.
And then when I came back to Los Angeles
I didn't want to get into baseball,
I just didn't want to be a coach or
anything like that.
And I took a,
I took one of those comedy classes just
to see if I was into just structure to
see if I liked it.
So I was living out in Tarzana and I
would drive to ucla every Tuesday or
Wednesday just to do it two or three
minute spot.
And I was excited about doing it.
It was like,
okay,
I think it's in me who's teaching the
class?
Pauly shore sister.
But for me it didn't matter.
She never even did stand up.
Right.
I don't know.
She may have.
What's her name again?
Sandy seashore?
No,
sandy shore.
Seashore,
yeah,
it is sandy sea shore.
Oh really?
Goodness.
Mitzi was so crazy.
So she actually,
she helped me and it gave me that
structure and then I did one open mic.
So it did help you.
It help me.
When did
you get out of it?
Like I've never heard of anybody doing
it.
I get out of it where they got anything
out of it other than just getting on
stage.
You got something out of that.
Three things I got out of it were one.
Um,
people thought it was funny,
you know,
made me feel like it didn't matter about
my jokes.
They thought it was funny.
So I got that out of it.
I got um,
I learned to make it visual.
I did learn some basic stuff about
comedy,
making it visual.
People told me I was funny between my
jokes.
My jokes are okay,
but it was funny when I got frustrated
with my jokes wouldn't work.
So they liked that.
They liked the fact that,
like I said,
it make it visual.
And then I did my graduating class at
the comedy store and the,
and the o r it was packed and I did it.
I did pretty good.
I felt like a comedian.
And then I did one open mic out in
Chatsworth and it was a,
not a disaster,
but it was desperate.
I felt like,
hey,
I went from being liked at the dor at
the comedy store and I'm a comedian now.
And so I went to that open mic and it
was just,
I could feel the desperation and I just
knew that this isn't the route I want to
go.
And I wanted to learn more about comedy.
So I took a business,
a comedy class,
and in that class the instructor told
me,
get out of Los Angeles.
That was started here.
Who was that instructor?
Uh,
Danny Robinson.
She owe me always a APA because an
agent.
So I just learned about comedy contract.
What comedians make doing a spot around
town.
He told you to get out of La.
Why?
Yeah.
Um,
go to a smaller market.
Go,
go find your voice there.
You know,
don't,
don't worry about having a bad set or so
and so.
It was good to see you.
You know what?
I would have agreed with that up until
this year.
This is 1993.
Yeah,
but I would have agreed with that,
like that advice and I've given that
advice before,
but I don't think it's necessary
anymore.
I think La has such a strong open mic
community too.
There's so many comedians coming up in
La and there's so many different places
to do standup.
I think it's just as good a place as any
to do to do comedy and I think that
guy's really the significance of the
club itself,
being on stage of the club and getting
seen is not nearly as much as it used to
be with now.
What's more important now is the
Internet is the fact that library guys
get famous from Philly.
They get famous from New York.
They get famous from everywhere.
They don't.
You don't have to be in front of a
specific group of people who can decide
whether or not to put you on television.
You just put your shit up online and
because of that,
because of phones recording sets,
so many people's shows are getting
online to like people are getting to see
the development of material.
If they want to look for it,
they could find,
you know,
cell phone videos of all of us,
on a regular basis almost.
You know,
you do a weekend at a club,
you do five shows,
someone's going to put a fucking video
online.
I mean,
I,
I think I'm glad I went to Seattle.
This is basically pre-internet because
it taught me about the three person
show.
It taught me about the MC,
the guest host,
the opener,
the closer clearing out the audience,
how you sat the audience.
I worked there as well.
Um,
which would work at this.
Was that comedy underground up in
Seattle?
Greg Club?
Yeah.
So I would see,
you know,
Patton Oswald Large Park or
they had the comedy underground and
there was another one that was run by
like a mormon or something like that.
Uh,
that was uh,
giggles by Terry Terry Taylor ran that
room and I would do that room is very
religious or something.
Who was the guy who got up in front of
Robert Schimmel and like apologized for
a set.
I don't know,
I just know that Terry Taylor is,
is or was Mormon.
Yeah.
And he ran giggles in,
in Seattle,
near the university there.
There's this famous story where a guy
got up in front of Schimmel and like
apologized for a set before he did it
because your demos really hilarious but
really dirty.
And uh,
he went up before him was schindler,
Bobby Slayton not sure which one,
but it was just an outrage through the
comedy community.
Like you hired this guy,
like why are you apologizing for him?
The people came to see him,
like,
why are you apologizing for him?
You knew what he did and you hired them
and the podium and he apologized for the
full.
Brought the guy up
before.
Yes.
Like I said,
this guy may be dirty and that doesn't
fit our value system here.
This is the alleged story.
Well,
they don't.
This is what I had heard known by people
who were there.
Do you mean they don't know?
I mean it was a big store that's spread
and I remember I talked about on the
radio once and the guy said it didn't
censor comedians.
He invited me to come down to the club,
but I never wound up doing it.
I did the underground.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's a good club.
Low ceiling,
all that.
Joe,
what would you.
So you would say to a comedian today in
2013 here,
say in Los Angeles,
somebody comes up to you and he goes,
Joe,
I'm a stand up.
I'm doing open mics here in La,
you know,
w,
w what he wants to be a stand up,
you know,
what will,
what would you say to Shay?
What would you say to a comedian
that go hang out at the comedy store?
You really would say that.
Fuck yeah,
that's what fear did.
See,
I wouldn't say that they're turning into
a standup,
especially not now because they cut the
open mics to one day now.
Well that's retarded.
That's retarded on their behalf because
that was one of the greatest things
about the comedy store's,
how much emphasis they put into
developing talent.
I mean the very few clubs have two
nights of open mic nights.
They fucked up if they did that,
but I'm not surprised.
You know,
they've been fucking up left and right
with a lot of different details,
but even when they had to open mics,
I don't know how many comedian it's off
the street.
A guy who drove here from Kansas City
and goes,
I want to be a comedian.
I'm going to hang out the store.
I mean those,
those.
Those are few and far between.
I think.
I don't think so.
You don't think so?
I think guys have made it out of La a
lot more over the last 10 years than
you'd imagine a lot of.
Started out in La.
A lot of guys started their standup
career doing open mics in La and then
went on to have like legit careers like
already does.
Ours are started at all in La.
He's a legit standing.
Okay.
That's one guy.
That's an exception to the rule.
I would think I know about that man.
I know there's a lot.
CAPRA low started.
There's another one.
There's a lot of guys who started out in
La.
There's a lot of goddamn clubs,
man.
Think about how many fucking clubs or
just within an hour and a half,
two hours of here is unprecedented
comedy.
Magic Club.
The improv,
the comedy store,
the laugh factory.
Ontario club.
Yeah.
Ontario Bray.
A vine.
You can go on and on and on and on.
It's still hard to get into those clubs.
House.
It's hard.
It's hard to get into those clubs
almost.
That's why you got to go maybe two.
I'm not gonna say a boise,
but go to a Seattle,
go to a Minnesota,
even go to a Chicago in those clubs.
I think it's easier to get people.
I think it's easier to get on stage in
front of a decent situation as a newer
comedian with a crowd in Chicago or
possibly even New York.
Maybe Austin,
possibly Minnesota.
Seattle.
Denver's getting a scene.
Denver hasn't seen.
They've had a scene for years.
You know,
I have a serious scene,
so I think there are spots there where
you can play those,
you know,
the,
the self promoting rooms and you have
build up and get a buzz going and then
come out and play some more rooms.
That was always my thing.
Philosophy.
You definitely can do it that way.
You definitely can do it.
Obviously many people have done that.
What I'm saying is you don't.
I don't know if you have to anymore.
I think La is not a bad place to do it.
I think there are enough diversity in
the rooms.
Like you got your hipster boom.
She got your blue collar room,
she's got your tour restrooms,
you've got your rooms.
Okay.
Through that and I don't know what.
Would it be a blue collar room?
Ontario maybe.
I don't know.
Saddle wrestling to do comedy anymore.
Do they still do it at the universal?
Oh really?
A universal.
Not the one on sunset.
No,
no,
they.
They do comedy.
The saddle ranch at universal.
How many on it?
They're a bunch.
It's fun.
How many different places have comedy?
Universal?
There's the lovetts club that they're
doing.
Standup again there,
right?
No more pot.
It was like a podcast and do podcast
now.
Also a girl from a d from a Improv now
runs it.
Really?
Yeah.
She runs that place now.
That's interesting.
That's a weird place to get to.
Shit's annoying to go through the
fucking parking and all that nonsense.
They find it.
They do have that thing now though,
where you can valet your car and then
they'll pay for the valet or as good
than someone's farting in your seats,
checking your glove box and yeah,
I got to do that.
Of course they do that.
Do you feel because it's you,
they.
They go out of their to do it.
I don't know what the fuck do.
What do.
It?
Depends on the individual obviously,
but I know when I worked for carwash
drove people's cars.
I know they do it.
I know they get inside their car.
They look around.
I know they do it.
I did it.
Everybody does it.
It gets getting in someone's car and
you're like,
what's in here?
But are they taking stuff?
For sure.
No doubt.
They take some people,
I'm not saying it universal,
they do,
but a friend of mine just got his
sunglasses stolen out of his car for
sure.
He put them on the front seat,
went to the,
went to where the fuck he went,
came back and said,
where's my sunglasses?
And they played stupid and he's like,
hey man,
I put them right here.
Like I'm not stupid.
That's stealing is a sin.
I don't care any.
I know another person who got the.
They had a little portable navigation
system underneath their seat that got
stolen,
but it happens all the time.
I know,
but what's worse than that are fucking
your sister having sex with your sister.
That's worth,
I think victim never done this to wants
it.
You want it?
I thought about that.
There's one thing I will go to my grave
saying,
I've never had sex with my sister.
That's a good move.
Yeah,
there's some things you want to keep off
the resume yet.
Well,
you don't even want to do it and then
go,
well,
that was a mistake.
Never do that again because you can't
really erase it.
No.
Kind of man because like isn't like
learning like one of the most important
parts of life.
Like shouldn't you be allowed to fuck
up?
But you can't.
There's certain fuck ups you can't make.
Like you can't be like,
you know a baby.
I want to marry you.
I want marry you too.
But I gotta tell you this one thing I
know,
I know this is not going to change
anything because we're meant to be with
each other,
but I fucked my cousin.
Your wife's going to be like,
what?
Why don't you fuck your cousin?
Wait a minute.
Which cousin?
Yeah,
how far.
Wait,
wait.
What?
How far I fucked my cousin Mike.
Huh?
How far was the,
is it a first cousin or is it a uh,
yeah,
it'd have to be a first cousin.
Second cousin.
Legal.
Well it's gay sex.
Um,
I think no one's going to be happy with
you.
Happy that you fucked your cousin.
But it was a joke brody.
But if it's a raised ranch,
my antlers,
if it's straight,
it's straight sex.
I think I'm the second cousin is
actually like legal,
like you can not only fuck them.
You can marry him,
right?
Yeah.
Jerry Lee,
Lewis.
Cousin.
Can I ask you a question,
Joel?
It not.
You've got to post to.
It's been on my mind and I know you
probably don't want to talk about it
because it was brought up.
Well,
thanks for bringing it up on the
Internet.
Well,
it was brought up as well.
I'm just being real.
Bruce brought up you.
I think you were uneasy with it.
It was an ice house.
Chronical.
I'm.
Why would you bring it up again?
Because I heard Joe talked about gay
sex.
Like I have to make it clear.
I'm not into that.
Oh,
why do you have to make that clear?
Because I get hassled for it.
Sometimes it goes back to you again.
Brody notice going back to him and gay
sex.
Um,
apparently you can have sex with your
cousin.
It's illegal.
What?
EMC.
If your cousins a transsexual,
then it's even more legal.
Depends if
you're telling someone who writes for
Salon,
you're in and a few girls that have been
attracted to their cousins,
but they always use the excuse.
They're not blood related and they've
all done.
Yeah,
that's not real.
I wouldn't have sex with a relative.
Just not into it,
but I think people have done it
throughout history.
I think it's Kinda sick.
Why?
I just don't see them that often.
I just think it's sick.
I.
I think incest is a sickening thing and
I'm sorry it's happened to some young
girls or kids or whatever.
Man.
It would have the name thing.
What if it's a cousin that you really
enjoy?
I think a cousin is too close,
but what of it?
Look what if that cousin is the perfect
person for you?
What if you know it does.
It doesn't make sense,
but you know what the heart wants what
it wants.
Brody and then one good and that's not
normal.
How much are you bothered by the fact
that the,
the main character on homeland has your
name?
I don't.
I'm bothered.
Should I be crazy?
Because what they call them,
brody on the show,
I'm like,
that's not it.
That's all you think of.
No.
Brody's you maybe the guy who wrote it.
I saw my name and thought about me.
I don't know.
It's all about me,
but no,
it doesn't bother me.
Um,
so apparently not only can you have sex
with your cousin,
but you can have a kid with your cousin
and dangerous.
Yeah.
My cousin pretty hot.
Apparently even having sex with your
sister is not,
it's not nearly as dangerous as far as
producing a kids with health risks.
There's no real health risk posed by,
um,
by having sex with your cousins.
I said percentage with sister,
uh,
it's probably not good,
but it depends on how much the genes.
I mean,
look,
you're,
the idea is that your sister and you
come from your mother and your father.
There's already some differences in
genetics,
a mixture of those.
Obviously your mother's side's from
different,
but if your parents were cousins and
then you fucked your sister and had a
kid who,
that's,
that's dipping into the same pool a
little too much,
which is probably something that was
like really common back in the day.
Like especially with um,
with uh,
pre-internet.
Yeah.
No,
with royalty royal people like royal
blood,
like one that's like one of the inside
jokes.
He's fucking closed.
Ised their eyes be the,
that close to each other.
Look all fucking weird.
It's because they're like,
they're fucking in the same genetic pool
all the time to have royal blood.
Royal blood.
That'd be making sense.
Why so many of them were fucking insane
and they think about how many crazy
things that kings and queens did.
Not just the power itself,
but the fact that they were in bread.
Oh,
we have something to do with it.
Amish.
I Bet I bet are inbred and a lot of
people in West Virginia,
I shouldn't say that.
They're gonna come get you.
He being shitting on the Amish.
They are red.
Bam.
You don't know nothing.
You don't know how to fire up a barn.
You don't have to make your own bar and
you're not even a man.
I love the fact that the amish get a
chance to go fucking crazy after they
become an adult.
It's called like bubbles.
Still skin or something.
They do.
What do you mean they get to go crazy,
bro?
Rump Springer.
Yeah.
They get a.
They go on.
Use Electricity.
The fuck they get to do drugs,
aren't they messed up?
I see.
Those amish shows.
They seem like they have.
They do have problems.
I think you're really generalizing,
sir.
I don't know.
The Amish.
The amish friends would like that.
That you're generalizing,
aren't they fucked up?
I sit on the show.
I didn't say the f word and I said no,
he didn't say fucked up.
Did I?
Brian believe you did.
They seem massive.
Fucked up.
Wind the tape.
I don't think I said the f word.
I don't think you said messed up.
That wouldn't sound right.
You're a grown man.
It doesn't matter.
I think more and more important.
I think more and more people are not
going back after the is still.
Skins are done.
Yeah.
Rumspringa also spelled
from spring.
I N G E or Rumspringa.
Hmm.
Okay.
That's the same thing.
Rump o s h spring,
uh,
is a period of adolescence where some
members of the amish community during
which a youth temporary leaves the
community to experience life in the
outside world.
Just sucking car.
Are they allowed to do that?
Yeah.
They're going off,
man.
They're allowed to.
And then they decide whether they come
back or they,
they,
they don't come.
We should.
They're allowed to go out and have sex.
These girls is fascinating.
Something that I didn't know.
The Amish.
The Amish is a subset of the anabaptist
Christian movement,
which I think was originally started by
Martin Luther and a $1,500,
a fucking amazing podcast by Dan Carlin
hardcore history podcast on Martin
Luther and the,
the anabaptists and all these people
that it was back in the time where they
first learned how to interpret the Bible
and put it in a form that was phonetic,
were a regular person could read it
because apparently before the 15
hundreds,
you really couldn't read the Bible.
You had to learn about it from a priest.
And if you were one of those rare people
that spoke Latin and read Latin,
then you could read it.
But I mean,
it wasn't like available to the public.
These were like sacred texts.
Like the idea that you get to a Bible in
every hotel room,
you know,
when you're,
when you're on the road,
how much every hotel room,
the gideons.
I mean,
they had the old Bill Hicks book about
remember to anybody ever seen to Gideon,
I'm going to capture Gideon.
He did a bit about,
uh,
like setting a trap and calling the
hotel room doesn't seem to have a Bible
in it.
You think you could send someone up that
he was going to capture Gideon,
but back then before Martin Luther
translated the Bible into a phonetic
form,
people had no idea what the fuck was in
that book.
They just had to listen to these asshole
priest tell them.
And then once he did that,
like they wanted people wanted to kill
him.
They're like,
it was like a huge change of philosophy
for,
for the whole Christian culture because
people started reading into the Bible
themselves and then there's all these
interpretations of it and Shit.
But I didn't know that the sub sect that
amish being was a subsect of that
window.
What the fuck happened?
They decided not to have electricity.
Like w.
what's that about?
I,
it probably teaches,
I don't know want to say family values,
but you really have to rely on each
other and go out there and
hunt for food.
And do they hunt though?
I think cut it up raw.
I don't know how they eat.
Well,
I mean,
I'm sure some of them may hunt,
but I think there are other whole thing
is farming,
right?
Yeah.
They're farming vegetables.
Kale,
maybe a
no apples.
Are they allowed to go to.
They ride bicycles,
right?
Did you ever see that Amish Mafia show?
Yeah,
that was a fascinating one,
but the,
the,
the show,
the movie on Spring.
It was the best.
That was one that got pretty real.
What the fuck is that movie?
I said that reality show with like the
amish kids kingpin to La,
but there was a movie.
What was the fucking campaign was good?
Yeah.
There was amish.
No.
Yeah,
kingpin was hilarious.
Devil's playground.
That's the one.
It's a documentary.
You want the 2000,
ten one or no shit?
No,
you don't.
I'm just a lot of like different
versions of it.
Holy Shit.
Devil's playground.
They've done like.
Why do people keep calling it devil's
playground?
You fucks.
You guys are ruining everything.
There's so many devils.
Playgrounds.
This is ridiculous.
How can you keep calling it devil's
playground?
Look at this devil's playground.
Nineteen,
28 and a Australian silent film.
Nineteen 37.
And American drama in 1946.
I drama.
Nineteen 76.
Hamadie and Australian semi
autobiography.
Two thousand two.
A documentary about the amish.
That's the one that's the one you want
devil's playground.
Two thousand two.
A documentary by Lucy Walker about the
amish period called Rumspringa.
It's really interesting.
And what I thought was really
fascinating about it is you see the,
like the confusion in the kids,
you know,
whether they get this weird break,
they get this weird break and they just
want to fucking drink and they smoke
cigarettes and get crazy and use
electricity.
I'm going to go check my local breadbox
she said a joke for this.
Is that you're saying for this?
Yeah.
I thought about.
I thought about for 20 seconds.
Should I say when I should say if you
thinking about it,
you lose the magic.
Brody Stevens.
I don't have to tell you that.
Steven Brody Stevens,
you know the rules.
Think about it too much.
Was the manager.
Who are you?
David Copperfield?
No,
no.
I'm Lance Bass.
Yeah.
I don't think they're really amish.
I don't think you're allowed to fuck in
front of a camera if you're amish.
I think it steals your soul for.
Is that Indians that were Asian?
I thought,
no,
no.
The Asian.
You're not allowed to see the vagina.
You know.
See pubic hair or the genitals.
They blur all that out.
Why would you?
Why would you want to see hair?
It doesn't look weird or it does look
weird.
Are you being racist?
You're talking about positive energy.
I go to Panda Express.
I know from what I got.
He's had some pixelation in his mouth
from a man.
I have not.
And that's,
that's me.
Take that back crying.
Please don't take that back.
That's going to get out.
That I had.
That has never ever happened and I never
ever want to do that.
So out there.
Thank you.
You just put it out there.
What is this?
Ten percent you keep saying,
why do you keep saying 10 percent?
Well,
by Brian keeps saying 10 percent.
It's a running joke based.
In truth.
I had some issues.
I had some situations in my life and I
like to put numbers on things and based
on these factors and experiences and
thought processes,
we came to the number of a 10 percent
gay.
I'm open with it,
you know,
it,
it's not.
What did you just say?
It's not.
I understand what you just said.
What you just said was a statement that
would really work if everybody knew what
you were saying,
but I don't know what we're saying.
So we,
you're saying is a 10 percent gay?
I'm open with it.
What does that mean?
Does that mean you're 10 percent?
Yes.
I came out on my podcast probably like
six months ago.
You came out 10 percent?
Yes.
What's so funny?
Is there any beers in there?
Jamie?
Go get me a beer.
I need a beer on this one.
That this is going to get.
No,
we don't have to talk in that and that
ashtray over this way.
An Ashtray.
Joe Needs a beer and an ashtray.
Cigar.
And it's also based on when you were in
the Philippines or Taiwan,
isn't it that you.
That that factored into.
Did you know a joe?
Did you know any of this part?
At this story?
I heard rumors online,
but since I love brody like a brother,
since we were brothers in the art of
standup comic comedy,
since we are old school comedy store
brethren were old school bro.
You and I,
we go back,
we go back man.
How many fun times that we had in that
place?
Tons.
I mean,
a lot.
Those are early two thousands.
You have
one set one night.
It wasn't the comedy store,
but at the Improv that I always tell
people about a turner room around
moment.
There was a moment where you were
onstage where um,
you were headed to the stage.
It was at the Improv.
It was a late night set.
It was really late night and the crowd
was just about fucking done.
They had seen a couple of scrubs before
you,
a couple people with on before you that
just didn't fucking,
just couldn't pull it off,
you know,
it was,
uh,
you know,
there's a totally different energy in
those late night audiences,
but all those sets that you had done at
the comedy store where you beat on the
drums when the on the chairs,
brody would bring chairs on stage and
drumsticks and pound on the,
on the chairs and,
and,
and just change the energy of the
audience,
make it like this,
this thing where you could feel the
energy again.
You took your shirt off and he starts
swinging it over your head and you were,
you were like cheerleading in the crowd
and you go,
come on,
it's me,
it Steven Brody Stevens is the less you
do it.
Yeah,
let's do it.
You,
you had music playing.
It was fucking fun.
I remember that night and I,
I had uh,
played drumsticks on the uh,
the metal railings and yeah,
you're not just trying to have fun.
And I did.
The improv is a good place for me to
open up and you know,
you read a room sometimes and you gotta
you gotta like you gotTa pick it up.
Sometimes you're going to sacrifice your
jokes,
but then it's like,
it depends like when you're hosting or
whatever.
But that was a fun,
sad,
you know,
it's having fun,
having fun matters.
It does.
And that's why you should tell us about
what happened in Thailand.
What wasn't fun?
It was.
You enjoyed it.
No.
To completion.
Everybody.
People hung out.
You know,
it's,
cops come fucking buildings on fire.
Bodies were everywhere.
What happened?
People hung out.
Look,
without giving,
without,
without giving too much away.
We do explain it in my show.
Um,
when you go to Bangkok,
leave us hanging,
you know,
I'll tell you,
but I don't want to give it away because
if people see you on the show,
you've got a big audience,
they'll see it on the show is again,
well,
I don't want to give away.
Trust me.
This is a puzzling case.
People are going to want to examine this
from every angle.
They're to want to find out.
I guarantee you the,
the amount of people that download that
ice house chronicles,
we brought this up.
They're going to go through the roof.
What number?
Brian?
Forty eight to figure it out.
Google it.
Okay,
awesome.
Saying as I went to Bangkok,
we had fun.
You go to an area where they all these
different bars and they have the other,
they have the get togethers,
the ping pong balls,
the,
uh,
the young Vietnamese girls who will sit
next to you for a coca cola,
that kind of thing.
May you watch them dance.
I'll dance for you.
They'll sit by your side.
They smell good.
Sometimes they're top.
If you really want to be with them,
you can spend the money and it's
actually not that much.
Okay.
I want to say that.
So they have a few areas like that.
A lot of the westerners hang out and go
there.
It's fun,
it's different and it's simple.
It's simple.
And then you go upstairs
and it's a little different.
You're getting a little like,
Whoa,
that looks a little different in there
that the bone structure's interesting,
but I see some other people dancing and
then there's this one club that you go
in and it's like,
I guess the best one up there and it's
just they're having a party.
It's fun.
The girls look like girls,
but you can tell like maybe some are
guys I gas,
but it was one of these ladyboy bars and
we're hanging out there having fun and
they'll,
you know,
they,
they will touch you.
They're very forward.
They will touch your leg,
but they look like girls.
They smell like girls.
They look like girls.
Dave had the treatments and you're
sitting there and you're alone by
yourself.
You're in,
you're in Bangkok,
you're working on hangover too.
They touch and it,
I,
it's normal to get aroused.
And it was interesting and I knew I was
16 hours away time zone from America and
I know Comedians have gone down to
Brazil or Thailand.
There's a whole history of it.
So I didn't really pursue it there,
but I thought about it and then maybe I
came back on another night.
I go,
you know,
people thought I was gay.
The you said maybe.
No,
you came back,
right?
Well it was there for like two weeks in
Thailand saying maybe I came back.
Well I'm have.
You're making the story confusing.
Okay,
well I want one.
Alright.
I came back another night.
I said maybe I will come back.
She said,
the reason why I stopped you want this
to be.
I mean at that point I'll probably three
percent gay and that's based off
getting picked on.
As a kid.
Like brody,
you walk like a girl,
you understand joe growing up in Tarzana
I got picked on a lot.
You saying that someone can make you
homosexual by if they picked on you
enough.
Three percent would be 100.
No,
three percent wouldn't make it a 100.
But if somebody as a child,
you're in third grade and there's a
group of girls or even guys,
you go,
oh look at brody.
Oh,
he walks,
he looks like he's gay.
You walk like a gay gay kid,
you're always smiling and it was like it
was a nice kid and then I guess because
of a tilted pelvis I walked weird and I
got picked on for that,
so I always felt like,
wow,
I guess I think I.
I'm gay.
Maybe.
I'm guess I'm gay.
I don't know.
Wow.
Wait a minute.
So there is this.
The secret.
Is this the power of suggestion?
Is that one of those things I.
it's a power of being bullied,
so being bullied can turn you
homosexual.
It didn't.
Percent three percent.
If they're saying it,
if enough people are saying,
brody,
you.
If I saw myself walk,
if I sat and I saw myself walk,
I would think skywalks a little gay.
Well,
if you,
if you think that,
why wouldn't you change your walk?
I tried.
I tried to get a lift in my shoe.
Which side is tilted?
Which ones don't?
Which ones?
I think my right shoulder.
You think I'll show it to you.
Do you know for sure?
Is this just only go to a voodoo doctor
udo?
It's like to be a chiropractor.
The chiropractor,
this is like a physical thing,
chiropractors,
doctors,
there's a lot of chiropractors that just
fucking move your neck around,
take your money.
Not a lot going on.
I've been to a good chiropractors and
I've been in chiropractice.
When you're like,
what?
What just happened?
That just keeps that guy $60 to rub my
neck for 15 seconds because that's what
it feels like.
Oh,
I'm going to adjust your healing or your
anterior posture,
your c seven,
the late throw some terms at you that
are like completely unnecessary and very
verbose and long and then the crack your
neck real quick and it kind of feels
good.
I love when they correct the neck.
Yeah,
it kind of feels good when they crack
your neck.
But uh,
I'm not sure if it works.
Not relieves like it's like a relief as
it.
I do that,
but sometimes it does.
Some guys are good at it,
but sometimes like what has happened
there?
I'd like to get a chiropractic and
massage.
That would be good for me to take care
of myself.
I don't care if it's a guy miss ms dot.
I don't take them.
I don't care if it's a guy chiropractor.
Okay,
I'll take a female misuse you don't like
as I would take it like a sports
massage,
but not for a baseball team.
Like,
hey bro,
you were hanging out with the baseball
players.
Do your.
Here's a Mizzou.
So if you get a massage from a dude,
you want the lights to be on.
Do you want like fucking Motley crue
plaintiff to be in the mall?
You don't want any scented candles are
fucking great music.
Great massages as a Jesus of Hollywood.
What's that mean?
Kevin?
Kevin,
but Jesus.
You ever seen that guy that walks around
Hollywood that looks like Jesus.
His name is Kevin Light.
No,
I haven't seen them.
I don't think there was a bunch of guys
a long time ago.
It might be confusing them.
There was a member of the religious
group that used to walk up and down
sunset guy would have a cross trapped.
This is different.
Different.
Different guy.
Yeah,
this guy's actually cool.
They would park in front of the comedy
store and argue with Comedians.
I remember I got in this huge argument
with them because,
uh,
they,
they started quoting the Bible and they
were like saying,
shit that's not in there.
And I was like,
it's not even in there.
You don't know the Bible just talking.
She could go away.
We don't want to hear it because,
you know,
Ari read the Talmud 12 hours a day for
years.
Yeah,
he knows that he went on religious
retreat.
Me Ari was insanely religious.
I don't remember exactly what the
fucking person remember those guys
moving around.
They're like blonde kids from mature
cross and with black kid too,
there was a black kid who was always
with too.
We ran them out.
So last we ran them out harshly.
Here's actually Kevin Right here,
the Hollywood.
Jesus.
He's an,
he's a really nice guy.
And he gives me,
he gives me massages in the public
struggle.
Sit on the chair,
I'll take the tension out.
He's good.
That's awesome.
He goes to everybody and he is the best.
Like he will separate your bones,
your muscles from your bones.
Why does he start a business?
And he probably could,
will help them out.
We'll promote it.
Does this guy a homeless guy?
You're a regular dude.
Regular Dude.
What does he do for a living?
I don't know exactly,
but he lives.
He lives in normal life.
Isn't it funny that you have to ask?
Because when you hear guys like a
Hollywood Jesus,
it's like a homeless dude probably.
You know,
like you don't assume that.
It's like a guy who's got his shit
together who just likes dressing up as
Jesus.
I think he does.
It was a rumor.
He does it for his mother.
His mother was really religious and say
to honor her,
he just wants to make people happy.
It's possible.
I'm like that.
I don't know.
It sounds good.
If I was going to write a comic book
about the dude,
that's what I would say I would make.
That is a good angle.
Yeah.
That would be the would be the inside
background story.
If I was doing do like a wolverine
origins on him.
I would say his mother,
he promised to his mother,
mother over a main religious and little
did he realize that as he was dressing
up like Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ type powers,
he found them because his mother wanted
him to dress up like that.
Well,
he,
he does.
Honestly,
he does have Jesus' light qualities if
you want to look at it that way.
It's really giving.
He's a good guy.
Smart.
He's supportive.
He's a.
He is a good soul.
That's awesome.
He imagined what we found out the close
like that,
like give you powers,
like if you were a certain cloak,
like there's a certain material that you
were that allows you to read people's
minds.
See the contents of a person's soul.
Brody Stevens.
Can you see my soul?
Like a lady boy outfit.
Thanks.
So anyway,
you go back to this place and you're
pretty much aware that you're hanging
out with
at this point five percent gay.
And that's due to due to things in
college due to two comments,
mostly to comment from three to five.
Like immediately smell.
You want to give me a real number so we
could fucking move on with confidence.
Joe Factory,
I'm factoring in the bullying ness.
I'm factoring in some baseball.
I blame you because I don't want to be a
part of.
You're not.
You're not pulling.
You know.
I love you.
Right?
Okay.
I went there.
Let's say six percent gay,
six Jesus Christ.
By the end of this story,
we're going to be at 86 percent.
I went to,
I went to Bangkok six percent gay and I
go,
you know what?
I'm in Bangkok.
Let me push it to the limit and see what
happens and if I like it,
I'm into it or if it humiliates me.
No one's around.
This is my big opportunity and I really
didn't do that much and I had the chance
so I didn't do that much.
What you said,
you got to Bangkok.
You were 66 percent,
six percent,
six percent when you got to Bangkok,
but then when you went to the place,
you knew they were ladyboys.
When you went back,
when you say you would have to say you
went a little higher than you were when
you got there,
and we'll go,
well,
it was more out of experience,
like to check this experience out,
check me out,
take the temperature.
But it was a good experience.
It was.
I mean,
what do you define as a gay experience?
Uh,
there's a guy in you.
All right,
hold on.
Is a transsexual a guy?
It's way closer to a guy than me.
Okay.
Have guys been fooled?
Make any sense guys.
But you don't even listen to Bebo.
You don't even listen to people.
I said,
it made I made an error.
is it a transexual guy?
No,
it's not as close to a guy's made.
Correct.
It's more a woman as a man.
It,
it looked and felt like a woman.
Here's the reality of transexuals did
just the cold hard reality.
It's just chromosomal.
That's it.
And as far as like behavior and
appearance and maybe even like,
like sex,
like you might enjoy certain aspects of
sex more with the transsexual than you
would an angry,
overweight cigarette smoking woman who's
got a head like a frying pan,
you know,
if you found.
What does that transgender woman.
This is the picture though.
Brody's with Brian.
Come on man.
What is the Internet?
You can't do that.
You're going to ruin everything for
everybody.
Keep going.
My point is I would rather have a sexual
experience with a transgender that was
really sexy and sweet rather than a big
angry woman that's built like a football
player.
Okay.
I'm with you.
If you wanted to have a sexual
experience,
if you're a man,
most likely want to have a sexual
experience with something feminine.
Yes.
And the reality of femininity versus
masculinity.
There's a line where shit gets blurry.
That rhyme.
That line is big.
Angry Fred flinstone looking women.
Yes.
Versus like Thai lady.
Boy,
that's actually very cute.
Yes.
Where do you go when you're in top?
Urine.
Fucking off the screen.
Urine,
urine,
Thailand.
You're alone.
You've got.
Even if you're not a Thailand,
if you're anywhere,
if there's only three people on the
planet,
it's you,
the Thai lady boy and the big Fred
flintstone looking angry.
I'm not going to be with the Fred
Flintstone or boogers in her notes.
I won't be,
I won't beat breath.
I'll let her give me a massage.
Her feet smell to transgender,
irregular curl though.
There was those two.
You could probably cut a nice young one
because he thinks,
I think that would be,
you know,
a different thing.
I think also there's the feeling of
exploitation that comes with having a,
uh,
having a sexual experience with a
prostitute that's a female that you
don't get if it's a prostitute that's a
male.
You know,
if you go to a female prostitute,
like there's this thing where,
you know,
if you think about the concept of
prostitution,
you think that women are being
exploited.
That's like one of the main negative
aspects of prostitution.
And then also as a father,
you start thinking,
well,
why are they prostitutes?
Most likely because they didn't have a
good family structure.
They didn't have a good father figure
that never a good mother,
whatever it was,
it's not good.
Most likely there could be some weird
that just enjoy sex and don't mind
getting paid for it because it's better
than being a waitress.
That's possible too,
but when you think about a woman,
most likely you're thinking about
someone being sexually manipulated and
someone being taken advantage of and
objectified and you think of a bad
situation,
but you don't think about that with a
guy you don't.
Especially a guy that used to be a guy
who used to be a guy and then became a
girl like and decided to do it because
he wanted to do it.
Like he made the choice wanting to do
it.
Felt like that's who he is.
He's better than they wanted to be.
Or did he like made a choice that you
definitely make the choice to have
surgery,
but you feel it almost like you have to
get it done?
I can't tell.
I mean,
there's no way I could tell you what
they feel,
but I would assume that they're telling
the truth and when I've talked to,
I mean we had bucking Joel on the
podcast who is a transgender,
a woman to man and you know,
he says that he's always known inside
that he should be a man.
I mean,
his personality was always,
and that's the only time he was ever
happy was when he was allowed to be a
man because this person feel real brody.
Well,
I went out from the path here,
the from the path here,
because I think what we're talking about
is actually a very important subject.
It's real.
Have to define it very clearly.
No,
no.
Hold on a second.
You have to define this.
Go Pee,
pee.
Okay.
Can I come right back?
Hey,
now we're not gonna.
Let you back in this door out there
punching a code.
I don't think that any one of us can
tell someone what they feel inside their
body,
and I've talked to way too many people
that say that they.
They know that they should have been a
man or they know that they should have
been a woman.
If that's the case,
if they're saying that I.
You can't argue with that.
The whole,
if you look at the spectrum of human
fuck ups,
you know the genetic abnormalities that
the variations in color of skin and
color of hair and the size of teeth and
all the different variations of human
beings.
Of course some people were supposed to
be boys and didn't come out.
Boys absolutely no doubt about it and I
think one day they're going to be able
to do something where they give these
people some sort of a genetic
manipulation and they're going to
literally turn them into double x
chromosome women.
And I think,
I think that's not that thing.
That's the beginning of like the ability
to manipulate the human genome,
the ability to change a person's DNA.
But until then,
what do they have?
They have,
they,
you know,
they have surgery and they have a
hormonal,
you know,
hormone,
hormonal treatments,
but if you had to choose between a guy
who did that,
a male born male who did that and became
like a really sexy transgender or
disgusting angry woman who hates men,
discussed getting disgusting,
angry eight women that hates,
then he would go with that.
Marius.
You're Alaris.
There's only three people on the planet.
Wait on the planet through the angry
project.
You're going to try to turn it into a
lady with a big giant,
stinky feet for a really beautiful lady.
Boy.
Definitely number one.
I would definitely be with a woman show
weight or you wouldn't be able to lady.
Boy,
I don't even know if I saw one that
posts like penises,
postsurgery peanuts as I wouldn't even
look at it because you don't have to
look at it.
How about you don't have to look at it
how much it comes with special goggles.
So,
so Brian,
like those three d glasses you get,
you look at it,
you get it through that.
She looks perfect.
Can I ask a question,
Brian?
And look at this three people on the
whole planet,
most likely I'd kill myself.
Let me tell you something.
It's three people on the planet.
I'm going to go to the highest fucking
mountain.
I'm going to stand there,
look at it,
and I'm going to say fuck it and take a
swan dive and then we're going to have
to start fresh because I'll be the last
bail on the planet.
There'll be no impregnated people.
And those two people are gonna die.
And that's going to be a wrap.
Unless they milk my balls for sperm when
they find my dead body within 24 hour
period,
my sperm staying alive,
most likely the human species ends
there,
Brian.
So yeah,
go with the tranny.
Is that okay?
You know,
transgender,
you can I ask one quick question?
I would be sitting there eating that big
fat,
real pussy getting stabbed.
I don't know that it was real pleased.
Pleasure.
Brian.
Please show if and when,
obviously I'm talking about on the
podcast and let's say this topic does a
appear on my show.
This lady,
boy,
10 percent issue.
Am I going to receive a lot of heat on
it?
Not only because
from who?
I don't know from America.
Fuck them,
man.
You're going to receive heat from people
no matter what.
No matter what you do,
there's going to be people that don't
like this to going to be people that
don't like that.
Dude.
You can't avoid heat if you're public,
you get heat.
Yeah,
but this is.
This is personal.
Public.
I've seen Neil degrasse tyson take heat.
Who's that?
How dare you?
You don't know anything.
I don't know what.
Don't say.
I don't know anything.
I follow sports.
Joe.
That's his ball.
Nothing about science.
Nothing about space.
I've heard of stuff.
I heard of Bill Nye.
I've heard a lot.
I love weather.
I love geography.
I like geography.
I'm into the moon.
Hi,
I'm so you're in Thailand.
Oh Gosh.
Here you go.
You're with the ladyboy.
You go back.
You go to the club,
right?
Sit down.
How do you know right away that this
used to be a guy?
Oh definitely.
Well,
you know.
No,
no,
no.
Let me.
It used to be is whatever.
I didn't see an Adam's apple.
Do you remember the episode of the
mantra that we did with a transgender
woman who is beautiful?
Her name was like vanity or something
like that.
Vaguely.
Remember that dude.
She was like really?
Pretty like Whoa,
like stunningly beautiful and was born a
man and we did a segment where the guy
got strapped to a table.
It's called make me hard and we put a.
I was strapped to a table.
We put a light box over.
Dick would go off when he got an
erection,
so of course we controlled the button so
it'd be like whenever like majors were
eating bananas or we had this
transgender get out and the transgender
does a dance for this guy and then she
puts a whip cream on her nipples.
The guys sucks.
The whip cream,
offered tests.
She had big fake tits and then she pulls
out a promo.
I remember that she pulls out a penis at
the end of this fucking light.
The light starts flashing pain,
Bang,
Bang.
It was saying,
I remember that her penis looked like
like a,
like a primate penis that had been
poisoned.
Like if you took a champ and you
poisoned the champ and he saw his dick
after he was dying of poison.
Let me ask the question.
What happens to the penis was just a
regular looking penis on a beautiful
woman with breasts.
Good skin.
That'd be an issue.
Hair.
The penis would be an issue for sure.
If you had to do something with it.
Like if the deal was like,
like she,
she's beautiful but she's got a dick and
she's going to blow you,
but you got to blow her.
No,
I'm out.
You said that's where you're out.
You're out on that.
Okay.
If you're at on that,
I'm out with you,
Joe.
Who?
Okay.
We're both out.
I guess I'm 10 percent gain.
There you go.
I guess September.
Second.
Thank you.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's.
Yes.
So you sit in there?
I loved it.
And what,
what,
uh,
did you,
were there any of them in they're
actually born women or was it all lady
boys?
Do you know,
I,
I probably,
I mean most likely made the lady running
the place was a,
was a woman,
but I think most of the dancers were,
were,
were male at birth and um,
but it's part of that culture.
Just to let you know,
it's very accepted to see ladyboys all
around working at starbucks,
walking down the street.
Why do you think that is?
I don't know.
It's just a,
I don't know,
it's a different culture over there,
but is it a cultural choice or is it a
genetic thing where there's a great
percentage of people that feel like they
should have been a woman?
I think there's something about
genetics.
I don't know about the,
I don't know if like Asians are the Thai
people are more apt to having that gene.
I would wonder if there's some stats for
that as far as like women to men,
transgenders like buck,
buck angel.
I wonder if there's some stats that
show,
like what countries have more
transgender women to men.
If type question.
I wonder if talent is Thailand actually
have more transgender men.
It's an accepted part of the culture.
I mean,
I bet you down in Brazil there's a lot
and it's accepted and maybe accepted
down there.
Right?
So,
um,
you can tell us as much as you want
about this experience where you can
enter right here.
I,
I'm willing to talk.
I'm.
The only thing I'm thinking about is I
don't want to give too much away on this
show and I will keep going.
People are going to see the show anyway.
That's awesome.
You've actually already said it on a
podcast before and we got you up to 12
percent gay.
Forget that.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
When you brought them up to 12?
Yeah,
we got him up to 12 because there was
something else that he does pr right
now.
Yeah,
I got confused in some peer pressure.
I feel like you guys will me a couple
more questions and bullied them into an
extra percentage of being gay.
That's how he got here.
He said he got bullied into being three.
He might've been how it was walking.
I think it was because you still like
pop click on like guy porn at home or
something.
I forget what I.
I'll tell you what
you can click on what that percentage.
That's residue percentage.
What are you working at?
Chernobyl.
Not Describing fucking nuclear power.
Power.
All.
I came in about being gay residential.
I came back quantum energy and on his
back I had at quantum gayness is what we
had access to you porn and I did wander
and click.
It's something I would never ever do and
it's something that it's,
you know,
it's like,
did people see brokeback mountain?
Did it any straight guy?
See brokeback mountain.
I'm sure there were.
I'm sure they saw two guys making love
in the movie or whatever and they
actually felt good about knowing these
guys loved each other and it may even
aroused a straight guy knowing that two
guys were passionately in love with each
other.
Let me take it from here.
First of all,
if you felt that from watching that
movie,
it means you don't have a sense of humor
and you probably weren't there with
another man who also has a sense of
humor because if you did as soon as jake
ellenberger no,
what's his name?
J Dot Gillman Hall,
sorry.
Jake Ellenberger,
who's an MMA fighter Gillen Burger
ellenberger is a professional mixed
martial artist.
Gillen Hall spits on his hand and then
shoves his dick right into right into
heath,
but I don't think you would.
You'd have to laugh a little.
I mean,
I didn't see the movie.
We're only human.
Shane.
Somebody's got aroused by that.
Who was not gay?
Oh boy.
I'm not sure I agree with you there.
I think if that scene a rouse you.
I think you're probably right.
I'm not saying the scene arouse you.
Maybe that to humans are in so love
together and it's.
It's passionate and it's almost wrong.
It's taboo.
Taboo.
There you go.
It's almost taboo to say that.
You know what?
That scene from brokeback mountain,
it,
it did start something,
but it didn't.
I never saw the movie.
I never saw them.
I saw it.
I never saw again married.
The relationship.
Heath herring and Jake Gyllenhaal was
very similar to one of my jokes is that
I think,
I don't believe in bisexual men.
I think there's gay men and then there's
really gullible,
straight dudes who get talked into
blowing crafty.
Gay Guys.
Me,
I'm 10 percent gay and I'm not sure what
that movie was was j dot Guillen Hall
was the really crafty gay dude and he.
Richard,
what is his name?
Ledger Ledger.
Heath Ledger.
I call them heath herring.
Heath herring.
Heath Ledger.
Sorry.
Heath heath herring is another MMA
fighter.
He's ledger was just like sort of a a
nine volt battery brain dude.
Just kind of a dude.
Wasn't that smart and he was out there
alone and hanging out with this guy and
a bunch of fucking sheep around and just
got into it.
Fuck it.
Got talked into it,
but it ruined his life.
Wrecked his life.
He really wasn't even gay.
He was talked into.
It was.
He had a family.
They just say,
I want to get talked into it.
You want to.
I would not.
Oh,
I thought you said I want.
I'm hearing things back to Thailand with
a lady boy.
And how does it escalate?
We went to the second floor.
What do you think when you're walking up
those stairs?
Biggest mistake of my life.
No,
I.
You know what?
I'll tell you what I wanted to see.
See if I can get it up.
See if I had the temptation.
I could do whatever I want.
This is my big chance.
Everyone says,
brody,
you're gay.
You're gay.
I know it's eight now I'm in a room in
Thailand.
You like,
I'll show you.
Oh,
and you know what?
I don't need to go into detail,
but I pushed it to the limit as far as I
could go.
Okay.
Did I perform?
I will go on record saying no,
I did not.
Never have.
Don't want to perform oral on a man.
Can I go on record saying that?
Gotcha.
But what,
what happened?
Well that didn't happen.
Okay.
What didn't happen also is kissing,
kissing.
Didn't want to kiss a man.
To be clear.
There was no kissing,
no kissing,
no race car driving,
no meteorite impact.
Many of the things didn't tell you.
Make an unromantic I'm sorry.
I apologize.
I'm very romantic guy.
Go on and
you know some stuff I tried,
you know,
touched this.
I did not.
I'll be honest.
I looked,
I looked at it.
How close?
No,
no,
no.
Probably.
What is that?
Three feet.
Two and a half feet from the ass or the
Dick.
I looked at the penis as a difference
because if you're three feet from the
Dick,
that's a safe judgment time.
You can move left.
You can move,
right?
Correct.
Three feet from the ass.
No,
I wasn't there.
You're basically there.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
Time out.
Are you saying three feet?
I'm talking about my face.
Your face.
Three feet from his dick or his ass.
Can I say one thing?
Can I say another thing?
Yes,
you can see whatever you want.
Never did.
Nor do I want to take my face and put it
in the advance ass.
Can I go on record saying that now we
know if there was any debate before it's
been squashed.
Okay.
Now your turn it around and I'm in
Bangkok and I go,
well,
people,
Sam gay,
turn around.
Let me look at it.
Far Away.
How far away?
Three feet from the deck?
Yeah.
What's it look like?
Is it hard?
At least I know.
I'll tell you what.
No,
it was.
It was what you described.
It wasn't normal.
Something happened to.
It has been poisoned.
Whatever.
There's some chemical.
Start injecting your body with estrogen.
I would assume you'd Dick shrivels up.
It's not necessary anymore and it knows
it.
Just like when you inject your body with
testosterone.
If you're a woman,
you're not supposed to have men's levels
of testosterone.
Plus those women in bodybuilders,
they grow.
Dick's think their clinic extends.
It's like when you find a dead body
hanging for like that's been there for a
week.
It's stretched and different things.
Different thing.
Brilliant.
Okay.
So the Deq was soft.
We didn't touch it.
Okay.
But when,
when you tapped it just to see what it's
like to say I'm officially touched it.
I've never touched a man's penis ever.
How do you,
how do you even know that you're in a
dream?
Unless you touch it,
right?
I guess,
yeah,
just touched with no stimulation at all.
It's like that thing that you do when
you're lucid dreaming,
um,
the way you like practice lucid dreaming
is by walking around your house and
every time you get to a door knob or
doorway,
you're knocking the doorway.
Am I dreaming?
And if you're not dreaming,
you feel it.
You knock on the door.
But if you're dreaming,
your hand just goes right through and
you go,
oh my goodness,
I'm dreaming.
And that's how you lucid dream.
So it's like a meditative device.
So whenever you see a Dick,
you should thump it and go,
am I dreaming?
No,
no.
I got set up here.
I just got set up.
We all dream about.
Joe Knows Dick.
I
don't want it to why you don't even want
to touch it,
but you did.
But you did touch her as a doctor with
touch as a doctor.
When did you get it to officially say
I've done it.
What did you do?
The residency in Miami State,
Arizona State.
Enjoy it.
Okay,
Doctor,
please consult.
There was no kissing.
I don't want to smell good.
She smelled it was a girl.
Well,
okay,
what point in time.
Here's the question,
when you become a transgender,
when do we decide to call you a girl?
Is it when you make the choice?
Because if you still have a penis,
becomes very.
I don't know if you have to have your
penis cut off.
I don't know if you have to be on
certain certain,
uh,
you know,
medication hormones.
I guess it's just for a courtesy.
It's just the person's choice.
Like if you decided tomorrow that you
want it to be a eustice,
this other girl's name.
What's the girl's name?
Dub becky.
Becky Warner Evens.
No,
you,
me,
you decide to be a woman.
Okay.
Becky Stevens.
I would start calling you a woman.
I would start calling you out of respect
out of respect.
And I'm taking hormones out of respect.
But did you know that there's queer?
Do you know a queers?
Those are like gay guys.
Like you've taken the word over?
No,
I'll lbtq t lesbian as lesbians.
Bisexuals,
a gay transgender,
queer.
The queer ones,
a strange one.
And the queer one is they want to be
whatever they want to be.
They want to be a man.
They want to be a woman and they want to
be,
oh really?
You want to be?
They want to be they or they want to be
it.
They didn't have a year.
They have different designation.
Fifteen percent queer that they choose
10 percent gay,
but 15 percent queer.
I liked it.
Yeah,
I like it.
We're moving closer to our goal.
I feel network and I'm selling queer.
We're moving closer to the goal of 86
percent gay by the end of the podcast.
We can do it.
Ladies and gentlemen.
All we need is more stories.
We got more brody coming up right after
this.
Look at the design of this.
We get this from China,
but let me assure you,
the quality is remarkable.
His lips are soft for any cock.
No,
no,
no.
Come on Brian.
Asshole.
Dude.
You're ruining everything.
We're so close to getting them up to 25
percent.
It's now joe.
No,
it isn't.
That's not solid.
It's not mine,
man.
Twenty five percent moment.
Task.
This is what I said at that.
I'm going to be honest with you at that
moment.
Okay.
At the moment where that guy is sucking
on your Dick happened in person all the
time.
I think you were 40 percent gay.
Are you?
Are you kidding?
For a moment.
This could mess with my house.
For that moment when I'm offering you is
a fluctuating scale of gayness.
You,
but I.
You brought me all the way up to as high
as 40.
When you come in a man's mouth,
he's giving you A.
I think I'm being very generous.
Very generous by often you were 40
because for most of the population when
you come in and man's mouth,
you hit 100 and you.
Yes you do.
Yes.
You did.
You say if you were in prison,
you got locked in prison.
Brody and I don't plan on going to
prison.
Just a nice guy.
I don't break any laws.
I D,
I defy you to find me like with prison,
if you will,
because that's the only place we have no
options is sexual part was I had no
options at night.
Most people don't go to prison.
Brody,
it's.
It's a dumb thing to bring up for.
Most people don't go to prison and when
they walk upstairs on their own without
a security guard,
having them shackled risk to anchor you,
like pretending they had,
they brought me to the mess hall and
then they suck my dick.
That's not what happened.
Okay,
go back.
Go back to me being blow back to that.
Remember that they didn't blow the
Buzzer and give you your one hour
outside to play basketball and you wind
up getting your Dick sucked.
That's not what happened.
Brody.
You made a choice to go up those stairs.
There's nothing wrong with it,
but you're to push.
I don't believe those number.
Ryan,
what do you think when you come in the
guy's mouth?
What are we up to?
I think was just say I did that.
I'm just assuming he's done.
I would say definitely 25.
I don't like your numbers,
Brian.
That's a shocker.
You've never brought that number up to
me.
I cannot believe that Joe said 40
percent.
Forty percent because I love you.
I should have said 100 man team and a
man's mouth.
Can I say something almost immediately?
Gaze.
Fuck.
Can I say I wasn't in fucking the guy in
the DD?
Spit it back into your mouth.
Brody.
What is more gay?
What is more?
I'm going to say something to you.
Hold on a second.
We'll move on and know what's going.
If you think of 40 percent gay,
the end of this,
probably think I'm 86 is our goal,
but you're playing games.
That's not what I said.
I never said that.
I'll tell you what.
You have fluctuating scan.
I'm going to get hammered on TV for.
No,
you're not.
You're going to be protected me.
Fuck yeah,
man.
I love you and America loves you.
Two,
you'll be universally protected.
The only people that will despise you
because of this are assholes.
Fuck down.
What are you?
Perfect.
You're perfect sexually.
No.
You keep your room clean.
Fuck yes I do.
You give brody Stevens a hard time for
being an 86 percent gay.
Not Eighty percent.
Right now we're at 40 stops.
The moment you decide it is the hounds
and it's down the hatch of a man's
throat.
Probably sacred fucking stubble and I
don't think that's so bad.
If you feel stubble on your balls and
your balls are clean
shaven,
it probably is a standard guarantee you.
There's at least 10 comedians that have
gone down to Brazil and had their penis
sucked by a transvestite.
Every time you try to rationalize what
you done by comparing yourself to the
acts of others that are also ridiculous,
you get another 10 percent gay.
Stop that.
So we're now at 35 percent gay or goal
is 86.
We got at least 20 minutes left this
podcast.
We can do this brody.
Well,
if I talk more,
I would,
I would probably come very close to
hitting your goal.
Oh,
I'm.
You'd come very close to hitting 86 if
you tried.
So look,
if you're on ecstasy and you with a
perfectly was on ecstasy like vanity
vanity from,
uh,
the man show.
Remember her?
Yeah,
she was hot computer.
I've pushed it to the limit and I know
what a race car driver roadie.
Alright,
stop saying like you breaking in new
tires.
We're trying to figure out these
compounds.
When we hit the skid pad.
That's not what's going on.
When you say and you push it to the
limit,
what are you saying?
What's with the euphemisms?
Brody,
let's get real with America because
America loves you and they love you the
most.
You telling the truth?
I said,
let's see how far I can go.
That's 35 percent gay,
right?
I don't think so.
Come on,
let's be real.
No,
no.
It might be a 35 percent gay thought
worth.
It's worth where we have only four
percent.
Where are we at the moment is what's
going on here?
She's sucking your Dick,
but is she tickling your balls?
Like is she probably.
Does she know her thing?
Does she know what the fuck she's doing?
Yeah,
they're decent,
but if you feel like the girls doing it
or do you feel like a guy's doing it?
That's beautiful.
I don't think about a guy.
You're not thinking about a guy.
She looks like a girl.
Make up the hound smell.
Feel harassed sexually.
Adam know.
I mean.
Oh,
sorry about that.
When you release the hounds,
is there any feeling of regret?
I didn't have any if that.
Even from what my recollection
recollection?
No,
no,
we use stone cold sober.
I was probably on a hookah and beer.
I think we hit 86 percent.
No,
we didn't.
That's I want to say this jail.
I'll talk about whatever you want
regarding this.
I'll be honest.
It is a subject that does make me
uncomfortable for just a couple reasons.
The other reasons that it is so public
and so what I know,
but it's going to want to make sure that
it's going to be on comedy central and
it freaks me out.
No,
listen,
brody,
what you.
Who you are is who you are and who you
are as awesome.
We love you.
I ain't no matter if you're 86 percent
gay or like everybody else in the room
right here.
Matter.
Let me say this.
On this podcast you allowed me to kind
of explain everything about express
yourself and I and I and I feel like
maybe on this
show,
and I'm not blaming anybody,
it can be my own neurosis.
I don't know if it comes across that
way.
Kind of how we explained it.
I know it's a TV show and I know this is
a podcast,
but that's where some of my anxiety
lies,
but the fact that we just talked about
this here does make me feel better and
knowing that you have my back,
no matter if you're 100 percent gay,
which not a lot of people not on when
you come in the guy's mouth you 100
percent gay.
A lot of people have said that I don't
agree with,
so I don't agree with them.
I don't agree with them.
Thank you.
But your third year,
86 percent.
I'm at that time.
I debate you on that.
I said 40 before,
but it's because I love you.
If I didn't know you,
I'd say 100 percent,
but I do and I love you and I don't
care.
I think you're 100 percent awesome.
I don't think it matters if you're a 10
percent gay or 25 percent gay.
Who gives a shit and yeah.
You know what lady boy,
as opposed to a gay man,
like if,
if it was a dude who looked like don
barris and he had a full beard and he
was sucking your Dick,
that would be a completely different
place that God doesn't appreciate.
God doesn't appreciate it.
I'm joking about God made gay people and
that's the Christian's conundrum that
God made gay people to God made
everything.
Why did God made sociopath?
You believe in God?
I don't know.
This is a reality.
Good question to answer.
I would like to think that science
provides me with a lot of answers to the
what,
how the universe works and I think it
does for the most part,
but I think science is discovering new
things every day.
Do I believe religion?
Absolutely not,
but I do leave open the possibility that
there could be some sort of a higher
power.
I don't know if it's a guy with a
fucking robe who lives in the clouds and
has a harp.
I don't know,
but the reason why I don't know is
because I haven't died.
I haven't been there.
I don't know.
Life itself is way crazier than a god
just life itself safe.
There's no god that made the universe.
There's no universal power that controls
this.
There's no laws that God the universe to
have an ever expanding degree of
complexity.
If there's none of that,
if there's no higher power.
Man,
this is amazing.
It's amazing if there's no one running
the show,
it's amazing that this happened.
It's amazing.
There was a big bang.
There was something smaller than the
head of a pin and by some sort of
reaction that no one can explain.
It exploded and this incredibly dense,
tiny object became everything you see in
the universe,
every particle of matter,
even the ones we can't even figure out,
like dark matter.
All that shit is so fascinating.
The fact that every fucking galaxy has a
supermassive black hole inside of it.
That's one half of one percent of the
mass of the entire galaxy.
The bigger the black hole,
the bigger the gap.
It's fucking madness.
And then the fact that inside every
black hole might be another universe,
supernovas and asteroids and lava and
Komodo dragons and pigeons.
The world is fucking crazy.
It's a mad,
mad,
mad world,
and to think that it's impossible for
there to be a god I think is ridiculous.
The whole thing's impossible.
A lava is impossible.
Oceans are impossible.
A rivers impossible.
Salmon are and possible a fucking
grizzly bears,
madness.
All of its craziness.
Every single fucking thing on earth is
insane.
All of it together is the fact that it
exists.
The fact that we're on a podcast and we
could broadcast instantly worldwide.
The fact that we have laptops that are
fucking inch thin and contained,
two gigabytes of data.
The fact that you could buy beer,
you don't have to fucking go get a wood
barrel together like an asshole,
like one of those moonshiners shitheads
and brew your own booze.
It's all madness.
Brody Stevens,
so I don't know if there's a god,
but I'll tell you what,
that comforts me.
The fact that you're not one of those
guys should go,
no,
there's no god.
Those guys haven't taken the test or
whatever.
I believe.
I'm like you.
I believe there's an higher.
There's a higher bain.
That's all.
I'm into prayer,
I believe and blast.
I'm not into the whole religion.
I like to think of more spiritual,
but basically like a chick.
You're selling a chicken.
My Yoga class.
How long?
What does that make me?
Ninety percent gay legend,
but I'm pretty spiritual.
Well,
I am.
I,
I'm not afraid to say it.
Sometimes I feel in Hollywood it,
if it's wrong to say you believe in God.
Well I,
you know,
I think it's wrong to.
I don't want to say wrong,
but I don't think it's a good idea.
For me personally.
I'll say this,
I'll try to be as a broadminded about
this as possible.
It's not a good idea for me personally
to believe in anything that I can't
rationally explain and see the work.
Like when I don't understand quantum
physics.
Okay.
And I've tried.
I've read a few books on it.
I've watched many documentaries on it.
I've had quantum physicists on the
podcast.
We had a [inaudible] Swami who's a
quantum theorists.
We had him on the podcast.
He talked his mystical wizardry to us.
I don't necessarily understand it
though,
and so when people say,
do you believe in quantum physics?
I got to go.
I think they.
They know,
they know what they're saying and
universally amongst them they agree.
Uncertain principles amongst all these
quantum physicists,
but me personally,
I don't.
I honestly don't know enough to say,
I know what the fuck is going on.
I trust them for sure that they're
telling the truth.
It's not just a whole group of liars
whose making Shit Up.
I don't think that's going on,
but when I say,
when you say like,
do you believe I grew up?
I guess I guess,
but I don't know.
That's the same way I feel about
religion is the same way I feel about
the idea of God.
Like,
do you believe in God?
I don't.
Dunno.
I Dunno.
I don't know.
And less so that then quantum physics so
don't know,
but you are assuming that you seem to
say no to religion,
but it's created by man.
There's make no mistake about it.
It's approvable.
We can show the lineage of religion.
We can show the new testament being
created by Constantine and all these
bishops.
It's been proven that there were certain
pieces of work but of religious work
that was left out of that.
They've made decisions as to what to put
in the Bible,
what to leave out of the Bible.
It's been shown that there's been a
metamorphosis of the Christian religion
from the jump.
There's a difference between the
original ancient Hebrew Bible and the
Dead Sea Scrolls,
which is the oldest version of the Bible
by like a thousand years,
and I think the only one that was
written in Aramaic.
So you've got the ancient Hebrew version
of the Bible.
You've got the translations from ancient
Hebrew to Latin and Greek into.
You know,
there's so many different things going
on.
There's so many different things going
on when you talk about like religion,
what you're talking about is what man
wrote down.
Yeah.
That doesn't necessarily mean there's no
god and I don't think you can ever.
I think the universe is so vast and
puzzling that to really decide that you
know,
how it all started and you know,
how what's going on behind the scenes.
You have to be a fool.
I don't know.
I don't think our idea of a god is like
a person with superpowers.
I think that's pretty ridiculous,
but I don't think it's impossible that
there might be some godlike quality
that's running the show.
There seems to be some fucking pretty
clear laws to this place.
There also seems to be some weird codes
that you find in things like the
FIBONACCI sequence is that the fibonacci
sequences of mathematical sequence that
you find in sunflowers and pine cones
and the shape of a person's face.
And the FIBONACCI sequence is also a,
it was used in a tool song.
Um,
I don't remember the fucking song.
Let me,
let me pull it up because it's amazing.
Um,
maynard maynard is just a bad
motherfucker.
He's just such an interesting creative.
Have you met him or Adam of the podcast?
Yeah,
yeah.
A couple of times.
It's,
oh,
that's it.
It's lateralis a l,
a t,
e r a l u s,
but he used the FIBONACCI sequence to to
like to make this song.
The FIBONACCI sequence is it's like zero
and then one and then two and then three
and then two plus three is five and then
five plus three is eight and it's this
exponentially expanding series of
numbers and the idea is that this,
this coding,
this,
these,
the golden section of the golden string
as it were as it's described,
is like the secret to life itself.
That life itself is this weird fractal
mathematical proposition and that you
see it in all these different things
like the nautilus shells and all these
different various fruits and vegetables
that have these bizarre shapes to them
and then this is all the fibonacci
sequences,
all the.
The actual underlying code of life
itself and that the fact that these
items are not random.
The fact that these things like
sunflower seeds are all governed by this
mathematical program almost shows that
there's something going on behind the
scenes that we can't quite describe.
And in fact there was a.
A quantum physicist that came up with
this theory,
that life itself,
that in the,
in the,
the lowest measurable levels of,
of the universe itself in the theories,
these quantum theories that these guys
are creating,
they're finding self-correcting computer
code,
a very specific type of computer code
that was created in the 19 thirties by
human beings and people are looking at
it as the possibility by seeing all this
stuff,
the possibility that reality itself is
an artificial creation that we're living
in
and I've heard that it seems like it
might be possible.
It's going to happen that this is just a
dream or this is a figment of
simulation.
So yeah,
there is no reality.
You know,
and this was discussed in the concepts
like people have tried to figure out
what is reality.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
The one thing that freaks me out,
I mean this is just basic for me,
it's just like looking up into the stars
in the sky and go.
It goes on forever.
Where does it stop?
Do you ever stop and think how many
dicks are out there?
You know what?
I wasn't not,
I'm not into that.
How long did you last when the guy was
sucking you off?
Yeah,
that's an important point.
Sending less than six days.
Probably.
Good.
It was a you up at 100 percent.
Good at 89 minutes now.
80 six is what it is.
Hey,
why don't you last though this ADC.
How long did you last?
You're going to set me up for another
percentage point.
I don't keep track of that.
I don't last long anyway.
So you were a bit intoxicated.
You were drunk.
I was drunk off diet coke.
Oh,
you said you had a couple of beers or
they.
I don't think they serve beers.
And these,
these top ones.
You gotta make your fucking stories.
Straight power.
What do you want me to say?
I'm drunk.
You were saying you were drinking beer?
I might've had a beer.
Two downstairs.
How many beers too?
I wasn't hammered.
Is that what you're asking?
I wasn't hammer.
No.
I'm just wondering whether when I'm
drunk I can't come.
It takes forever.
Dick doesn't get hard.
It doesn't work.
If you got so excited,
even though you were drunk,
might have to kick you up.
The 92 percent guy I.
I made a choice.
I followed it and I was pleased with
what I did.
What were you pleased the boat,
the amount of ejaculate with?
Do I have to?
Am I going to have.
That's what I'm saying.
Like.
Well,
you said you were pleased by the result.
When I a lot,
I like to look at it.
If I have like a big fucking load that
comes out of me,
I'm impressing myself.
Did he look like a squirrel with an
acorn after he was done with you?
Well,
first of all,
I get impressed when I see my boogers.
If I blow my nose and it's a big fucking
water snot and a tissue,
I get excited because you're cleaning
stuff out.
I liked when I pick it too.
Even though you're not supposed to.
Why are you not supposed to pick your
nose?
Because it's bad for your nose.
You turbinates and flame.
It can cause sleep apnea.
If you just do that because deviated
Septum by picking your nose.
Your nose is very sensitive.
It's you're not supposed to be digging
in there.
I pull hair.
Sometimes they get ingrown hairs and
they grow back.
Or then if you could have nose trimmer,
you fuck.
That's the way to go.
Science.
They figured it out.
Neil degrasse Tyson invented it.
Who is he?
Exactly?
How dare you.
They had to come out his nose.
Yeah.
How much I,
I,
there's a condom.
Thank you.
Good move.
Otherwise you get the super aids.
They probably,
you know,
I didn't.
I just don't want to get reckon I don't
wreck it.
I don't want to get.
We'll take the Tarzana hat off and
you're all set.
I don't.
I don't want to be rid of.
It can be your move.
Like Larry the cable guy.
If he doesn't have that fucking shirt
on,
no one's going to know who he is.
That's a very clever move on his hat.
Wear a baseball hat and wear a shirt
that way when he's not.
When he wants to dress up and go to a
restaurant.
Already know what he looks like.
A regular fucking redneck slides right
into the door.
She'll go on.
How much did you come just happened?
If it says,
if it sounds wrong,
the way I'm asking you,
you know,
correct me.
I'm new to this game.
It's,
it was uh,
it was it.
I did it and that was it.
I,
I pushed it and it was a good.
I wouldn't say it was good.
It was like,
well,
I did it.
Hmm.
That's like,
is that like eating and Kentucky Fried
Chicken or is taking a really good shit?
I had more lean towards Kentucky Fried
Chicken,
Kentucky Fried Chicken.
It's pretty fucking good.
It's good stuff.
You know,
I went gluten free,
but that's one thing I miss mom.
I Miss Kentucky.
Okay,
now,
I mean,
you,
you've had me say a lot of stuff.
Joe Are my.
Am I going to get negative tweets based
on listen man,
if you do those people are assholes.
You didn't do anything wrong.
You didn't hurt anybody.
You want to have fun.
You went to have fun.
He did it with someone who wanted to
have fun with you.
Who gives a shit?
Yeah,
man,
it's on them.
It's on all of them,
man.
Who Cares?
We'll wait to check.
Tweet glutton for punishment.
You love it.
You're hoping they're metal.
I don't enjoy it.
I don't want to elevate homophobes
sample.
I usually say antisemites.
How much do you use the a?
You should say that.
If they say the key things,
if it's a Jew,
things calm homophobes oh,
switch.
Confused the fuck out of him.
Dude.
I don't want to.
I don't want to waste to hate on it.
I just want to be honest.
No,
I don't want to hate camel.
I just,
I'm sure I'm going to have to deal with
some negative stuff here and there on
twitter or whatever or you get no matter
what.
All right,
well maybe a couple emails,
but.
So what?
I'm positive.
I feel good.
You're awesome.
HIV positive?
No.
Brian.
Fuck you man.
Speaking of which Dallas buyers club,
I don't want to just that movie bring it
up because it has a lot of your people
in it,
but it's a great fucking movie.
Might people,
Texans.
Aren't you from Texas?
I've been to Texas.
What do you mean my people I know you
sell well in Texas.
Dallas buyers club is a matthew
mcconaughey.
He's not gay.
Nobody lost a lot of white female
fucking bull rider.
Okay.
He says Manley's a gets.
And um,
he got HIV through unprotected sex.
Shame on him.
The first guy in the history of the
world.
In fact,
are you serious?
And he was the only guy I ever heard
that Sam Kinison joke about it.
They'll believe it.
They say sam,
they say AC,
heterosexual disease.
Straight people dive into want fucking
guy
pull,
pull.
Pull up that.
That's a class kinison.
It's a fucking classic.
He was the greatest Sam kinison on,
uh,
on AIDS.
On heterosexuals.
Yeah,
sure.
Dice had some crazy bits to back.
No kennison more.
Sorry.
Kinison was the kindness center.
He was a groundbreaker and I'm a dice
fan,
but Kennedy was the groundbreaking,
you know,
Kensington became kinison.
His book is fascinating.
My brother Sam is a book.
Has his brother wrote about being Sam's
brother and it's like no holds barred
behind the scenes.
Everything did come out a few years ago,
many years ago.
I think I read it in the nine to get it.
You get it.
But uh,
he got,
he got hit by a car.
He did,
yeah.
He was a young boy and he got hit by a
car and it changed him.
When you get hit by a car,
all of a sudden,
different guy,
as soon as he recovers from it,
they say that happens,
man.
I've heard that.
I read about like,
people wake up and they're different and
they actually know how to play the piano
or there was one recently about that.
This guy,
he,
uh,
got a severe concussion and then they
saw playing music.
He started a.
He had all this fucking musical talent
that he never had before.
And yeah,
teenager credits,
musical talent to head injury was crazy.
In fact,
this happened to a friend of mine.
Her son was never artistic at all and he
got a motorcycle accident.
He crashed.
He hurt himself pretty bad.
He's pretty fucked up.
And he had some serious brain injuries
because of it means fine when you talk
to them,
you would never imagined talked to them.
Seems totally.
No.
But because of that,
he's like super artistic now and he'd
never had that before.
I'm not saying you should fucking put
your kid in the head.
They can't draw pictures.
Good.
But there's something that happens
sometimes to people when they get head
injuries and with Kennison,
his brother said he just became
fearless.
Oh Wow.
He's gotta read.
I gotta read up on that crate book.
Dude.
It's a great.
Could you imagine if he was still
performing today?
Like where would you see Kennison if he
was still performing today?
Like what would he be at where you know,
what level do you think it will depend
entirely on whether or not he was clean
and sober.
Okay.
And it wouldn't even have to be clean
and sober,
but you would have to straighten
his act out enough to get his health
together.
Because what happened with Kennison is
if you go back to kinisons first CD,
which is louder than hell.
It wasn't even an accident.
That CD was on cassette and it's really
hard to get louder than hell is in my
opinion.
It's like the all time greatest comedy
album ever.
The groundbreaking,
there had been nobody like Kennison
before,
but when you go from there to have you
seen me lately,
pool,
there's a big drop off,
drop off,
and then from there to the other ones,
wow.
It gets worse and worse.
The further the distance you go,
because he couldn't keep it up.
Man,
there's no way you can keep up cocaine
every night and she fucking vodka and
Jack Daniels and he's 350 pounds.
He's five feet tall,
is unhealthy.
Everything's wrong.
Addiction in every form.
Sexual cocaine,
alcohol,
blackouts.
He was going hard man,
and he used to talk about it too.
He's talk about how he would get.
He had bits about it.
How do you get to a party?
And they'd go,
well,
isn't it?
It's you.
It's easy.
If you guys do coke,
he'd go to a part of it.
Let's put a little line out for they see
me and they go,
oh,
and they fucking spreadable.
And he talked about doing this gigantic
line of coke and almost having a heart
attack.
Did jokes about the fact that people
expected him to be this mad party animal
and the doesn't have the act itself took
a back seat to the lifestyle,
the act,
the act itself took a backseat to the
chaos.
Like a lot of comics go.
They fluctuate like you'll like one
special better and then the next one
maybe you won't like it all and then the
next one will be even better.
You know,
there's guys that I really love but I
only love like even prior there's some
of his is ones that I don't enjoy as
much as other ones.
Eddie Murphy,
same way you know,
but you know,
they go up and they go down depending on
how much attention they're putting to
the act,
depending on how much other stuff
they're doing on the side,
what's going on in their life.
But in my opinion,
Kennison is the best example for young
comics or what can happen,
how you can go from,
in my opinion,
being the greatest of all time with
louder than hell to being really
mediocre towards his later work.
Like just no joe.
I mean,
are you saying that is like,
look at this as what can happen to do,
you don't want that?
We definitely don't want that.
So who would be somebody not the
opposite of Sam?
Somebody who kind of turned it around a
little bit or.
Or did you turn it around and turned it
down but maintained the level and even
improved on Louis?
CK is a good example of.
Okay,
there you go.
David tells a great exhibit.
Tell Dave attell constantly maintains
constantly.
Dave Chappelle's,
another you see Chappelle,
Chappelle had that incident,
didn't do what was their tour.
And Hartford.
I did the whole oddball tour.
What the fuck happened there?
Um,
I'll tell you what.
First of all,
that Hartford show was late.
Okay.
So everything was set and they said,
well,
why don't we do Hartford on a Thursday?
Most of the shows are done Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
So they said,
let's do Hartford on a Thursday and the,
and these are the shows we did,
you know,
Dallas,
Houston,
Austin,
New York,
Boston,
Detroit,
big cities.
Hartford's not really that big of a
city.
Anyway,
Thursday night the ticket sales are kind
of soft and they released a lot of
tickets so I went on and did my thing on
the side stage.
It was fine.
I didn't notice any like bad energy or
these guys are punks or white trash or
tough or whatever.
I had fun and then I went inside to the
amphitheater and it seemed okay.
I mean you couldn't hear.
I mean it wasn't sold out.
There's maybe 10,000
people there so.
But the acoustics were all that great
and the acts weren't having all that
much fun based.
I think of the acoustics maybe a little
bit of the crowd.
And then Dave went on and actually I
left.
I kind of right after you went on,
I shuttled back to the hotel which is
around the corner and then Jeff Ross
came back in.
It was just on twitter that,
that Dave Chappelle start reading a book
on stage and had a meltdown and you
know,
it was just sitting there and smoking a
cigarette and caused,
you know,
not chaos,
but they were like booing him or walk it
out.
And that was it.
And that just started the buzz,
like he had a meltdown and I saw him
that night in the elevator and I'm not
really friendly with them.
He knows my face and he was just
basically basically still fuming at the
audience knowing like they,
they almost don't know comedy.
He was upset with the audience at that
point.
And.
But you didn't feel like it was about
audience when you are on stage.
Wasn't a battle.
Yes.
My experience,
my little stage that I would do for
every city,
it was par for the course up to that.
I mean that was our fourth show.
So you think they were saving their
Douchey ness for him?
Maybe.
I mean,
I don't know what they were saving it.
I just think that maybe because yeah,
that maybe that attracted that kind of
crowd that's going to yell out stuff and
like prego up Chappelle for good about
flight of the conchords.
So we're drunk.
It's Thursday night.
It's hard for,
you know,
women with the flight of the conchords
went on before.
Yeah,
they always would.
How long does that go on for that?
Here's the deal.
They did very well.
They were solid.
They would do about 55 minutes.
They have a very big following.
So they.
The conch big following.
Yes are awesome.
They have a very big following and to me
they were have to chime in there.
Awesome.
Because I love them.
They're great.
I love their show to does have anything
to do with this.
Okay.
But every night they came on and they
did their hour and they were solid.
They kept the couples happy.
They had fans of the show.
There's monitors everywhere.
Occasionally you would hear someone who
were Chappelle once in a while and then
other people just sat there and they
know,
okay,
Chapelle is going to come on an hour.
They had a set list and then chappelle
would come on and do his thing.
So I thought it was,
you know,
it was a nice.
It was good bit of the doing the lineup,
having Chappelle closed it.
Yeah.
That's weird
though to go on after a musical act like
you know that as a comedian when the
musical act goes up and then you go on
afterwards.
Weird energy.
Well,
I mean you had,
they would end and then the.
Then the Dj starts up,
then you get the hip hop going.
It changes the whole vibe.
It's about a 15 minute switch over 15
minutes.
Yeah,
10.
It's not like goodnight flight of the
conchords boom,
Dave Chappelle.
It's like,
okay,
I've music.
They're done.
They take the stage off and then the hip
hop guy starts going.
People were dancing and feeling good,
like excited.
Chappelle's going to come out and then
maybe after eight or nine minutes the
curtain drops and people get more
excited.
And you didn't exactly see the actual
city that particular night at Hartford
that moment?
No.
I saw,
you know,
I saw.
I either would watch chapelle take the
stage from the side of the stage or I
would watch him from the audience take
the stage and probably,
you know,
13 out of 16 times I saw that.
Well he's.
Anyway,
he's a great example of a guy who hasn't
gotten worse.
Got,
got it better.
Probably Bill Burr,
another example,
bill burrs on the rise.
Joey,
Joey got better already movie.
I saw him.
He's in one of the commercials for that
Deniro still thing.
Yeah.
Should be interesting.
So there are guys that are getting
better,
I guess you know,
Kennison for whatever reason,
maybe the drugs got to him the fame.
I know he would do that main room and
it's all the above,
man.
All the above can get to you for sure.
Anything can get to you.
If anything that takes your focus away
from the actual art itself.
I found that before when I'm too busy
with my life that my comedy suffered too
busy with other stuff outside of comedy.
My standup suffers and that's the worst
feeling.
Like I don't mind if other things I do
don't work that well,
but what I really mind is when stand up
does not work that well,
that that really drives me fucking
crazy.
It is different just being off stage for
three to four days.
You go back up there and it's was like,
Whoa,
this is kind of wobbly.
I'm a little different.
I mean,
that's how I feel,
you know,
just maybe at the comedy store for
example,
or you know,
one of these shows around town.
Yeah.
And when you take like a couple of
months,
all I've never done that.
I've never done.
That isn't a weird.
Comedy is one of those things.
It's almost like running like you have
to get in comedy shape,
comedy shape and stay there,
stay there,
don't fuck around.
Because if you get out of comedy shake,
it's carried hard to get back in.
I've had that feeling and it's not fun.
Not Fun,
but I,
I mean I've heard you mentioned a lot
how podcasting is like cross training.
I believe it is.
I believe podcasting is cross training
and oddly enough I think that podcasting
and stand up also help my,
my mma commentary.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And that made commentary for me is like,
you know,
we,
you and I have had many conversations
about sports because I don't know shit
about sports.
It's always a goof when you try to
explain to me something that's
happening,
but MMA is the only sport that I really,
really,
really pay attention to and I'm,
I'm watching every fucking thing I can.
I watch all the access TV fights with
smaller organizations.
I watched,
I watched probably 15 hours of mma a
week.
You're watching it as homework or just
you'd love it?
I just like it.
I always like it.
I watched in the background while I'm
writing.
Sometimes I like watching fights.
I've always liked watching fights and
not just like,
I don't.
Not necessarily even for brutality.
I watched like Jujitsu matches where no
one gets hurt.
You guys just tap.
I like watching technique.
I like watching guys who know what
they're doing.
I like watching people overcome specific
challenges.
Like an MMA in my opinion,
is probably the most difficult physical
challenge a person can,
can attempt to try to be an MMA
champion.
So when I see,
you know,
if I watch or more ties and other thing,
I watch a lot of.
I watched a lot of kickboxing,
a lot of kickboxing.
Man,
whenever it's on tv,
I watch like the glory promotions or
Gloria is this new organization that's
on Spike TV,
fucking incredible man,
the highest level kickboxers in the
world and they're all fighting on spike
TV and they've got this big organization
called glory.
So it's developing all this new talent
and it's also like getting people really
excited about kickboxing into the same
sort of the same way they got excited
about mma.
And I think that,
um,
whether it's that or whether it's
wrestling or Jujitsu or kickboxing,
what I get out of that is I get out when
you watching the best guys in the world
do something,
whatever the fuck it is,
especially when it's something as
dangerous as combat sports,
you get a charge out of watching people
perform and compete.
And I find that it's very motivational.
It's very inspirational.
It's very motivational.
It gives me energy and you're right
there ringside,
you feel it.
And then you're obviously in the,
in the octagon after the.
You're feeling that.
Yeah,
you feel it,
man.
You feel it.
You hear the slap of the impact of Shins
on heads and you know,
and thighs and fucking fist to belly.
You feel all of it.
You feel the body slams you.
You'd be feeling on the table like,
uh,
my,
my hands on the table and when guys get
slammed,
boom on the mat,
I literally could feel it in my hands
often.
And that,
that helps you have a better empathy for
these guys.
Yeah,
well I've always had empathy and
sympathy or tried to relate.
You know,
I've never fought in mixed martial arts
before,
but I had a lot of taekwondo match.
I had a lot of kickboxing,
I had a few kickboxing matches,
but a lot of the time,
kickboxing,
a lot of times sparring,
a lot of,
a lot of years invested in martial arts
and martial arts competition.
So I,
I kind of have a sense without doing it,
of what it means to these guys.
So it means a lot to me,
but there's a lot of issues with,
uh,
with,
with MMA as it stands today,
you know,
judging and there's a lot of issues with
the way he fights are scored,
the actual scoring system itself and
refereeing.
And is it something that's fixable?
It's just typical growth of the sport.
It's not.
No,
it's definitely,
definitely stuff that's fixable and the
UFC has done its best.
I think they need to update the gloves
too.
I think there's too many.
There's a real problem with guys getting
poked in the eyes.
There's a lot of that.
I really don't like that at all.
It drives me crazy.
It happens too often.
It seems to me like,
you know,
there's that old expression doing the
same thing over and over again and
hoping for sanity,
the definition of insanity.
And that's what we're doing with MMA.
We do the same things over and over
again.
We have these open finger gloves and
guys keep getting poked and we're having
a lot of detached retinas out.
A lot of guys are having eye surgery.
Like Michael Bisping had eye surgery.
Uh,
Alan Belcher had eye surgery,
got quite,
a few guys have had issues with their
eyes and so that's a fixable problem I
think it is.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
you're right.
Civil Issue Mittens are dead,
right?
That was my,
actually my,
my idea was to come up with something
that it pads the knuckles,
but there's like a smooth cover over the
tip of the fingers,
a smooth cover because in grappling you
don't really grab like this,
you grab most of what you do.
You grab like this,
you look and gene labelle was actually
showing me yesterday the way that he
does it,
which is different.
He likes to squeeze down on all the
fingers.
He likes to get his thumb in here and
squeezed down like that because it feels
like it's harder to break and he might
be right there.
Um,
but in any case you're okay doing this
like palm to palm,
like that's a deviation in the way you
have to grapple anyway between straight
grappling with no gloves on an mma
because of the size of the gloves
itself.
And then maybe they do,
they do.
They do use gloves?
Yes.
Yes you do.
Is there a bear gloves anywhere and kind
of not in America,
but I'm sure they're still doing it in
other parts of the world.
I mean,
I'm sure in Brazil that was how it all
started out.
I'll start out called they called it
valley Tudo,
which means anything goes and I'm with
the early UFC.
It was bare knuckle.
In fact,
tank Abbott was the first guy to
voluntarily wear gloves.
He decided to wear these chuck norris
gloves used to buy from century.
You decide to wear those into the
octagon.
I'm pretty sure he was the first guy in
the UFC to wear gloves and then
[inaudible] started wearing those
gloves.
A lot of guys started wearing those
gloves and then it became mandatory.
But when Vito or fought in the UFC when
he was 19 years old and a dose in
Alabama,
UFC 12,
he wore those gloves and no one else had
ever seen those fucking gloves before.
Besides a tank.
Abbott,
you know,
like no one I think.
I think.
Yeah,
I think it was tank Abbott was the only
one who had warned them,
so vito or wearing them to a bare
knuckle fight,
like I know a lot of the guys that were
in that tournament with him,
they were fighting bare knuckle and came
out and because of the padding on the
gloves you could really tee off on guys,
you don't have to worry about protecting
your knuckles.
Yeah,
you're not going to hurt your nose.
So that's been,
you know,
that was the first thing that they did,
the adding of the gloves,
which I think was a good step,
but I think the next step is really
figuring out how to cover the
fingertips.
Too many guys are getting poked.
Speaking of the poking,
can I use the restroom real quick again?
I'm sorry.
I use the restroom.
We're going to wrap this up.
Okay.
I'll be right back.
When your show is brody.
Enjoy it.
When is it on brody Stevens.
Enjoy it every Sunday.
Nine o'clock at night.
Who's your lead in?
What's on right before,
you know,
it's 12:00.
Has it been tosh?
I thought it was 12:00
at midnight,
right?
What?
I say you said 9:00.
Oh,
I get confused.
Nine o'clock midnights for the next six
weeks,
so two and night.
Six weeks to go.
Beautiful.
12 episodes to a night for six weeks.
So let's watch the shit out of that show
and make brody a Goddamn star.
Here's the thing.
I'm going to come back though and then
we'll talk.
Let me go urinate your preview.
Okay.
Here we go.
Never seems like he's doing material at
all.
He's just yelling,
color Jewish.
I just get it.
Is never was about the jokes.
It was about the in between of the
jokes.
Why did you not?
He really was so different from
everybody else doing comedy that we saw.
He used to be strange and it was always
just funny.
Then it just became strange from the
network.
That doesn't do drama.
I think I asked him,
are you on your medication?
And he said,
no.
Here comes a brand new drama where you
in a mental hospital.
It's about family are right.
If you get some jokes,
this is part of the process.
Having your mom tell you that you're not
funny.
Friendship.
Hey Zack.
It's brody.
Okay.
Brody Curry.
I have a telemarketer on the other line.
Was funniest when he's lost.
Complete control.
Brody offstage.
Onstage.
Not much of a difference.
You're going to hang out with brody.
He just have to enjoy it.
I mean,
pardon the Pun.
If I watch this thing,
I'm thinking this brody guy
is weird.
Yeah.
Brody Stevens.
Enjoy it.
Comedy central's verse drama.
New episodes.
Sundays at midnight and starting
December first.
I like how they call it drama.
Why are they doing that?
Because it is very documentary style.
Brody.
Like they just follow them around pretty
much and hang out and like edit it
together.
Yeah,
but it's funny.
So that was at a drama.
Yeah.
It's because there's a lot of drama in
it.
I guess
you know what they're doing.
They're just avoiding calling into
reality show.
Yeah,
true.
That's what they're doing.
They're calling you out our first drama,
which is probably smart.
That avoids the stink of reality,
I think.
Yeah.
The word reality show because of like
the Kardashians.
Exactly.
Ponchos and all this nonsense.
Well,
you know,
they're bullshitting you,
you know that it's set up scenarios when
you see a setup scenario,
if they're set,
you don't have any of that.
Yeah,
we can call it the drama.
I think it shouldn't be a drama.
I think it should be the actual reality.
Comedy Central's first drama.
So it's a joke.
It's a joke.
That's a joke.
I mean there is drama,
but then there's also compensate.
You want to know what's comedy?
January 24th.
I'll be at the Chicago theater tickets.
Go on sale tomorrow morning.
Early presale starts early.
It'll be on my twitter.
I'm the a presale password is finale.
That's January 24th.
Uh,
I don't know who's going to be with me.
We haven't figured it out yet,
but we're going to have a party bitches.
It should be a lot of fun.
Chicago in January.
How do you go wrong?
And we'll be back tomorrow with that
dude who worked for marine land.
Should be pre fill filled the mirrors
should be pretty fucking fascinating,
man.
This is gonna.
Be really bizarre.
Can I talk about all the shit that he
went through at marine land and a
training a Walrus and apparently it's
going to tell some disturbing shit.
What are you going to?
Uh,
just me and brody and Sam Brody said
he's not going to.
I'm going to check with my sister.
I'll know for sure tonight.
She's sending me these files and excels
and download
and joy yet
enjoy it.
You got it.
The Crest Theater December 13th with
Tony Hinchcliffe and at the Mirage in
Vegas on December 27th with Brian Cowen
and Joey Diaz.
She's off the chain bitches that,
that showed that when it's talking about
his December 11,
by the way,
at the San Jose Improv.
Okay.
That's a different show.
Sam Brody Stevens,
Brian Red Band,
Sam Tripoli San Jose Improv,
an awesome venue.
One of the best clubs.
Ninety eight percent confirmed an 18
percent gay.
That club.
It's interesting that the club is 50
percent less scaling whatever theater in
Sacramento.
That's December 13th.
And again the Mirage,
December 27th.
I'll be at the aquafresh theater.
Getting your shit together.
Brody,
we love the fuck out of your buddy and
don't let anybody give you a hard time
online.
They can all go fuck themselves man.
All of them.
You got it.
You've been a friend,
Joe.
I felt.
No,
I love you for being here.
Thank you.
Red Band.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you.
Ting.
Could have Rogan.ting.com
and get your freak on Rogan.ting.com.
Save yourself some money.
Bitches.
Thanks.
Also was today.
Carbonite.
God dammit,
I to figure out a way to better organize
my shitty laptop.
How about that?
A carbonite.com.
Use The code word j r e and get your
free trial plus two free bonus months
with your subscription.
That's carbonite.com.
And the offer code isj a r e n of
course,
thanks to on it.com.
It's o,
n n I t use the code name Rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
we'll be back tomorrow.
A lot of shit going on folks.
Lots to come.
Lots of cool people next week as well.
And in the future we got cliffy be
common.
We got Stefan Molyneux,
we got a lot of very interesting guests,
Ladies and gentlemen,
and we're looking forward to talking and
you know,
whatever listening,
I guess,
keep it close on.
Keep your shit together.
We'll see you soon.
Enjoy it.
Oh.